Auch ich könnte mal kurz abrenten, damit David was zum Aufzeichnen hat. Ich hab Verwandtschaft auf dem bayerischen Land. Auch welche, die jahrelang gelitten hatten. Dann kam wieder Alice und hat richtig richtig rottige Witze angeboten. With 2 megabit downlink at 200 kW uplink. They dare to offer you 2 megabit for 38 euros.
Aber das ist doch genau die Partie, die Leute vom Kongress 2012 beschwert haben, dass eben ein bisschen zu viel davon war, dass wir auch wieder ein bisschen mehr Technik brauchen, damit wir da eine bessere Waage haben.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein Hacker-Kongress, das ist ja klar, aber ehrlich gesagt kann ich diesen Eindruck nicht bestätigen, dass es da einen Mangel an technischen Inhalten gegeben hat. Und gerade der letzte Kongress war ja nun auch sehr stark davon geprägt, was einfach die Zeit uns vorstellt.
Ja, da kamen wieder mehr die technischen Sachen. Weil die 2012 halt ein bisschen zu kurz kamen. Da haben sich viele beschwerden.
Auf dem 30C3 war auch nun genauso viel Politik. Aber wie gesagt, man kann es jetzt inhaltlich nicht eins zu eins gegeneinander vergleichen, weil es ist einfach eine andere Zielgruppe. Die Republik erreicht einfach auch Leute, die wir mit dem Kongress einfach nicht die Bohne erreichen. Also es ist einfach... Diese Veranstaltung schafft es, in einen Teil, auch einen aufgeklärten Teil dieser Gesellschaft rein zu strahlen, den der Kongress mit seinem Konzept so nicht erreicht. Der Kongress deckt wunderbar diese gesamte, den ganzen Nerd-Level so vom Körner nach unten nach oben irgendwie bis zu einem bestimmten Layer. Aber ich würde sagen, der Kongress geht so im Osi-Schichten-Modell so maximal bis Layer 4. Und die Republika, die ist schon eher so von Level 3 bis 7 unterwegs.
Ich glaube, die anderen Layer gefallen mir besser.
Aber Layer 7 und Layer 6 zum Beispiel und Layer 5 sind ja verkannte Layer, wie ich finde. Also die meisten Nerds kennen wahrscheinlich diese Layer noch nicht mal. Kannst du sagen, wie der Layer 3, Layer 4, kannst du die benennen? Weißt du, wie sie heißen? Layer 7?
Das hab ich im Studium alles mal gelernt, hab ich wieder vergessen.
Irgendwo ist das Applikation-Layer 8 oben.
Ja, Layer 8 ist klar.
Politik und Religion, 8 und 9. Politik und Religion.
Ein Layer 8 ist der User.
Und das 7, die App?
Genau, 7 ist die App, ist nämlich der Application Layer. Genau. Der Layer 6 ist der Presentation Layer. Das ist ein Layer, der sozusagen nur dafür da ist, um zu abstrahieren, wie man etwas...
Die Modell ist doch schon längst zerschmolten. Die oberen Layer sind doch schon alle...
Nein, die oberen sind gerade noch im Takt.
Was ist ein Presentation Layer?
Wo der ist?
Auf 6?
Ja, aber was macht der genau? Im OS, im sonst wo?
Postscript zum Beispiel ist ein Presentation Layer.
Oh Scheiße, noch mal, dieses ganze Modell ist echt ein bisschen zerfleddert inzwischen. Macht euch da nicht dran fest, dass...
Naja, das ist was ich meine, genau.
Die gehen ineinander über und zerfliesen so ein bisschen.
Also, so wie ich es damals verstanden habe, haben die RFCs ja irgendwann versucht, irgendwie ihr Gedöns in den OSI-Schichtenmodell da reinzukloppen. Aber so richtig hat es ja nie gepasst, weil OSI war ja ein ganz anderer Standard.
Es ist halt ein Modell. Es ist halt der Versuch, eine Abstraktionsebene einzuziehen und nicht jedes Protokoll lässt sich nun wirklich genau irgendwo einarbeiten.
Eben.
Aber gerade wenn es um High-Level...
Deswegen bespricht ja auch keiner über den Presentation-Layer.
Ja, aber der Presentation-Layer ist wichtig. Weil wenn du einfach mit der Außenwelt nur in Layer 3 redest, dann bist du einfach der Vollnerd. Du kannst mit Layer 8 nicht mit Layer 3 reden. Da ist einfach zu wenig Übersetzung und zu wenig Erklärung drin. Und es ist schon wichtig, wie du etwas präsentierst. Es ist auch schon wichtig, mit welcher Endanwendung du letzten Endes nach außen trittst. Und Layer 4 finde ich auch cool. Das ist der Session-Layer. Also das ist auch, gerade wenn du so Multiplex-Operationen im Netz machst, was weiß ich, Druckerprotokolle, Terminal-Multiplexing und so weiter, da musst du einfach in Layer 4, 5 und 6 denken. Und wenn du das jetzt mal auf die Wie rede ich mit der Gesellschaft auch überträgst, auch da musst du dir sehr viele Gedanken machen, wie ist mein Timing, wie plane ich, wann ich eigentlich mit wem in welcher Reihenfolge rede und vor allem, wie setze ich meine Inhalte dann auch wirklich um. Das sind einfach alles Sachen, die irgendwie auf 4, 5 und 6 Unser Chef korrigiert ist gerade. 4 ist Transport, 5 ist Session-Layer, 6 ist Presentation-Layer.
Denk nicht in Layern, denk in Schichten.
Oh man, der bringt mich ganz sicher da.
Ich hab's auch gerade aufgemacht. Also, ähm, ja, ich weiß nicht, also...
Egal, ich wollte über die Republik reden, wir müssen jetzt nicht über Lehrer reden.
Ja, und du wolltest wissen, warum wir nicht da waren. Ich hatte, ich weiß nicht...
Ja, ihr werdet alle eure Gründe gehabt haben, aber wenn du jetzt sagst, man geht nicht zur Republika, weil die riechen ja alle nach Lulu und sind irgendwie Hipster und so...
Das war mir zu politisch und zu...
Das ist einfach nicht der Punkt.
Die riechen mir alle zu wenig nach Lulu.
Was denn?
Ich wollte nur sagen, Republika ist schon okay. Und da geht was und da sind wirklich viele gute Inhalte und da sind viele gute Leute, die sich einfach auch über wichtige Sachen kluge Gedanken machen.
Ja, das bestreitet auch keiner.
Und es gibt sogar ein Sendezentrum da unten.
Ja, es gibt ein Sendezentrum.
Obwohl, wie gesagt, jetzt mit Sende geht.
Ja, naja, das stimmt natürlich.
Das muss man nochmal so einklammern dann.
Also ich hab leider selber nicht sehr viele Vorträge live sehen können. Aber ich hab ein paar nachgeschaut. Leider noch nicht alle, die mit Sicherheit empfehlenswert wären, was so die Nerd-Fraktion betrifft. Also Frank Grieger hat ja einen Vortrag gehalten. Den hab ich leider noch nicht ganz nach. Also, was heißt nicht ganz? Den hab ich noch gar nicht nachgeschaut. Hab ich nur ganz kurz reingepiekt. Wer soll uns regulieren, heißt der. Sicherlich sehr zu empfehlen. Dann gab es ja auch so eine ganz interessante Debatte, wie soll man jetzt mit dem Snowden-Skandal umgehen und der ganzen Überwachungsgeschichte. Wohl berichtet ist natürlich dann immer der Vortrag von Sascha Lobo. Der ist, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen mit...
Publikumsbeschimpfung.
Ja, Publikumsbeschimpfung, das ist ja sein großes Ding. Im Wesentlichen, ihr fördert das Ganze zu wenig. Ihr spendet zu wenig Geld an passende Institutionen. Da kann man jetzt sicherlich auch verschiedene Perspektiven aufmachen und das nochmal debattieren. Das will ich jetzt hier gar nicht das Fass aufmachen. Eigentlich hat er einen sehr schönen plakativen Vergleich, indem er einfach den Vogel des Jahres präsentiert hat und mal geschaut hat, was allein dieser Vogelschutzbund in Bayern irgendwie an Mitteln und an festen Mitarbeitern hat, um da irgendwie der Sache des Vogels irgendwie nachzugehen. Im Vergleich zu den nicht wirklich vorhandenen fest Angestellten im Bereich netzpolitischen Aktivismus. Was ich aber empfehlen möchte, weil es nämlich meiner Meinung nach immer der lustigste Vortragende von allen ist, wo einfach viele kluge Gedanken durchs Hirn gehen, sowohl durchs Seins als auch dann des Zuschauers. Das ist Felix Schwänzel, auch bekannt als xixwirres.net. Der macht immer sehr überlegte Vorträge und arbeitet dann auch meistens schon die Vorträge der anderen, die er gesehen hat, gleich wieder in seine Präsentationen mit ein. Wie ich lernte, die Überwachung zu lieben. Sätze empfehlen. Was soll ich noch zu empfehlen? Mein Freund Moritz Metz, ganz schöne Sache, der hat eigentlich einen Radio-Feature gemacht, das hatten wir auch bei uns in der Sondersendung, über Orte, wo das Internet ist. Also, wo das Internet lebt, heißt der Vortrag, und da berichtet er so ein bisschen über seine Reise. Und er ist halt an all die Orte gefahren, wo das Internet so ist. Also versucht, Rechenzentren und Netzknoten ausfindig zu machen, hat das Dezix besucht und befragt. Hat versucht, irgendwelche Glasfaserkabel die Stelle zu finden, wo sie in den Ozeanen gehen und hat dann auch in den USA so Orte besucht, die dann wohl eingezäunt sind, wo diese Kabel dann ankommen und wurde entsprechend verscheucht und hat irgendwie Larry Pages und Mark Zuckerbergs Heimanwesen aufgesucht. Also war es ja wirklich eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Es gibt da noch eine ganze Menge zu holen. Es ist sehr viel online. Ich glaube, es sind 192 Videoaufzeichnungen allein auf YouTube von der Republika. Also richtig fett. Und alles, was nicht in Video aufgezeichnet wurde, gibt es wohl als Audio-Aufzeichnungen mindestens. Das kann ich jetzt gerade gar nicht sagen, wo die dann liegen.
Was hat der Knight Rider-Typ hier auf der Republika zu suchen?
Das war einer der Gründe, warum ich nicht auf der Republika war.
War das jetzt nur so ein Marketing-Gag von einer Republika? Oder von einer Firma, die da auftritt? Von einer Firma, die da auftritt. Und warum so viele Firmen?
Von F-Secure. F-Secure war quasi einer der Sponsoren. Wie heißt der Typ nochmal richtig?
Miko.
Ich vergiss jedes Mal seinen Namen. Ich weiß nicht warum. Jetzt schlage ich es nochmal nach. Na, gucken wir mal hier. Blablabla. Miko Hüpponen. Hüppönen.
Hüppönen.
ganz schlechte Witze in den Chat machen bitte.
Dann müssen wir lachen. Wir lachen sehr ungern. Ja, also, äh, Mikko Hüppern hat da so einen Talk gemacht, in dem er im Wesentlichen seinen etwas skurrilen Pledge für mehr digitale Freiheit gemacht hat und F-Secure hat da irgendwie ein Wiki aufgesetzt und will jetzt irgendwie so einen offenen Brief da rausbringen und sammelt Input und ist alles so ein bisschen... Ich weiß nicht so richtig genau, was ich davon halten soll, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es viel Welle machen wird. Na ja, ich hab mir das so zwei Drittel der Veranstaltungen. Also ich hab nicht mehr mitbekommen, wer gesungen hat.
Aber die Republik ist schon so ein bisschen mehr commercial als der Kongress, oder?
Definiere commercial.
Genau, all so ein Shit.
Na, es gibt Sponsoren. Es gibt Partner und es gibt Sponsoren, die halt da mehr oder weniger große Geldbeiträge beitragen, damit diese Veranstaltung überhaupt bewuppt werden kann.
Das heißt, die Republik ist ja auch schon ziemlich groß, aber die haben keine tausend Engel, so wie der Kongress.
Die haben ein paar hundert Engel.
Es sind ein paar, ich weiß nicht wie groß die Zahl war, aber auf jeden Fall signifikant dreistellig. Also da haben schon sehr viele Leute geholfen.
Und immer noch so viele Sponsoring.
Naja, also den gehört nicht die Halle.
Der Kongress gehört dem Ding in Hamburg auch nicht.
Ja, aber der Kongress spielt nochmal in einer anderen Liga. Hier werden zum Beispiel die Leute, die sich ein halbes Jahr mit dieser Veranstaltung um die Ohren langen, die werden auch bezahlt zum Beispiel. Und nicht komplett ausgebeutet, wie das irgendwie im CTC das ist.
Das ist alles freiwillig.
Ja, das ist einfach, das kann man nicht miteinander vergleichen. Trotzdem gelingt es halt auch, die Preise im Zaum zu halten.
Was kostet da der Eintritt?
Ja, ich hab auch Speaker. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, was die Ticketpreise waren. Aber ich glaube, es gab so Early Bird Geschichten. Da kamst du irgendwie für 80 Euro oder so was oder 120 Euro rein. 150 Euro.
Na, der fahr ich mal Motorrad.
Viel ist das nun auch nicht. Alles gut. 40, 50 Euro für so eine Konferenz. Ich meine, du hast da irgendwie 8 Tracks oder so, 192 Talks auf Video. Ich meine, das ist jetzt echt nicht wenig. Also, das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Ich finde, die Veranstaltung ist auf jeden Fall da.
Ich finde aber ehrlich gesagt 8 Tracks eher abschreckend.
Darüber kann man diskutieren. Ich finde es auch eher abschreckend. Ich finde auch weniger ist mehr.
Also, ich finde es schon beim Kongress mit drei Tracks immer schwierig, sich zu entscheiden.
Es waren doch noch mehr.
Das waren...
Es gab ein A bis E.
Ja, es gab viele Orte, ob das jetzt alles als Track gilt. Es gab 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Stages. Und dann gab es nochmal A, B, C, D, I, T und J. Und nochmal das und das. Also es waren noch sehr viel mehr.
Hast du nicht gesehen, auf welcher Stage du warst? Auf welcher Stage das Sendezentrum war?
Für Tarzan.
Nee, steht für Tim.
Also wenn mir da jemanden gefallen hätte tun wollen, dann wären wir Stage S gewesen. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall gab es da viele große Bühnen und dann gab es halt relativ viele kleine Orte. Also wie wir einer waren, auch auf diesen Ständen teilweise, was weiß ich hier, dieses Medieninnovationszentrum aus Potsdam. Die hatten da auch so eine eigene Bühne. Die haben alle noch mal so ihre eigenen Sachen gemacht. Eigene kleine lokale Workshops mit den Leuten, die da halt gerade in dem Moment da rumstanden. Was ich eigentlich auch ganz cool finde. Da passiert einfach viel.
Eines von diesen Projekten war auch einer meiner Kabelkunden dort. Die haben sich dann beschwert, dass das Netz nicht geht. Bin ich dahin? Ich dachte, warum steckt denn hier eigentlich kein Kabel in dem Switch? Na ja, wir haben irgendwie gestern, und es ging irgendwie nicht, keine Ahnung. Dann haben wir ein bisschen so. Ja, aber ein Switch geht nur dann gut, wenn man da auch mal reinsteckt.
Ist jetzt nicht unbedingt jedem immer so geläufig.
Nee, nee.
Eigentlich wollen wir auch weniger Kabel, ne?
Eben, genau.
Wir müssen jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr über Max reden, finde ich.
Genau, den Vent bräuchten wir jetzt.
Lass mich kurz die Sache noch abschließen. Haben wir alles gesagt zur Republika. Also eins noch. Republika ist okay, und da sollte man hinschauen. Und der Kongress kann auch noch eine Menge lernen von der Republika. Weil es gibt ein paar Sachen, die haben sie da wirklich echt gut hinbekommen. Gerade was so Präsentationen auf der Bühne betrifft. Programm, Darreichungen. Da kann man sich schon einiges abgucken. Also gerade so die Hauptbühnen, wie die so visuell ausgekleidet waren, mit so diesen super breiten Projektionen, wo dann so die eigentlichen Präsentationen und Speaker-Cameras quasi so digital draufgemischt wurden und wo du sie dann auch immer an unterschiedliche Orte platzieren konntest. Das hatte schon was. Also es war von der gesamten Präsentation und auch wie so dieses ganze Theming der Veranstaltung umgesetzt wird.
Ich fand dieses Assassin's Creed-Theme gar nicht so übel, ehrlich gesagt.
Assassin's Creed-Theme?
Du hast nie Assassin's Creed gespielt, oder?
Das Spiel, wo man alle erschießen muss?
Nee, dieses Netz, was da immer so rumwabert und diese Bildstörungen, die du dazwischen hast, das ist Assassin's Creed. Das ist so, wie das Spiel aussieht, wenn man da in dieser virtuellen Welt unterwegs ist.
Also jetzt geh ich auch zur Republik.
Ich kenn mich da jetzt nicht so aus. Ich bin ja da bekennender Nicht-Checker.
Hast du denn schon 2048 geknackt?
Ich bin, was ist mein Highscore? Und mein Highscore ist 66.916, was so viel heißt, dass ich 8192 noch nicht ganz erreicht habe.
Aber 4096 schon.
Mittlerweile hab ich's raus.
Jetzt wirst du doch mal in einem Spiel gut, Tim. Siehst du mal.
Ja, nee, so ist das bei mir immer. Ich entdecke dann ein Spiel, das spiel ich dann aber auch erst mal ein halbes Jahr.
Ja, da ist ja noch zu tun. 1634, ich komme, ne?
Das hält noch vor. Also ich wette ja auf jeden Fall, bevor ich hier nicht die 8192 gecheckt habe.
Bin ich ja froh, dass ich trotz der anfänglichen Zweifel, die du da diesem Spielern entgegengebracht hast, von denen, ich spiele ja und so, das geht ja alles gar nicht, ich und spiele, dass das doch so gefruchtet hat.
Ich weiß, welcher Art von Spielen bei mir verfängt und das gehört definitiv dazu. Zweierpotenzen, das ist auch cool. So, Schluss jetzt mit Republika.
Hättest du schon.
Ja, wenn du jetzt aufartend bist, Huckel, dann darfst du das nächste Thema festlegen. Ach, zu schade. Dann kann ich mir nämlich mal ein Bierchen holen. Möchten noch jemand Getränke?
Ich nicht. Aber ich wollte die kurze Pause dazu nutzen, dann kann Huckel noch ein bisschen nachdenken. Ich hab ja letztens meine Reifensammlung zuhause gepostet und die ist gesponsert bei euch von Flatter. Und da wollte ich mich nochmal bedanken.
Deine Reifensammlung?
Ja, ich hab ja für beide meine Mopeds neue Reifen gekauft und hab den Preis ein bisschen minimiert, indem ich halt mein Flatter mal ausgelöst hab. Weil ich wollte die Reifen mit Paypal zahlen und Flatter zahlt ja nur nach Paypal aus und dann...
Really?
Das ist ja schön.
Voll toll.
Durch die kleinen Episoden-Knöpfchen jetzt.
Wenn du die jetzt mal noch pro Livesendung machen würdest, wär viel tollere.
Genau, falls ihr nämlich jemanden noch nicht mitbekommen habt, Flatter hilft wirklich sehr. Also wenn euch dieses Programm gefällt, Flatter ist die beste und effizienteste Methode...
Was kauft ihr denn von eurem Flatter? Dein Kugel hat ja auch immer so dedizierte Ausgaben.
Damals ja, aber mittlerweile... Vitale Equipment.
McPros gekauft.
So viel ist das nicht.
Nach dem dritten McPro verlierst du da auch irgendwie die Lust?
Nee, aber immer mal so alle zwei, drei Monate kommt dann so ein Sümmchen zusammen, wo man dann doch mal wieder sich so ein kleines Dankeschön auslösen kann. Also ich bin auch großer Flatter-Freund und wünschte auch, dass das noch viel mehr Leute wieder und so... Also ich weiß, das hat man ja schon oft drüber gesprochen, aber ich weiß ja auch immer noch nicht so genau, warum das eigentlich nicht total durchstattet, weil das konzeptionell eigentlich voll toll ist.
Ja, weil es natürlich nur für uns cool ist und nicht für die Leute, die es ausgeben.
Doch, für die Leute ist es auch gut.
Ja, aber diese Einstellungen haben nicht alle.
Aber einige haben das und das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine kritische Masse. Genau, die sind cool, sehr cool sogar.
Ja, ich suche noch Ideen, was ich denn mit der Flatterkohle mal machen könnte.
Gib mir!
Kriegst du auch bei dir. Hast du nicht abgehoben? Dann kommst du bald in so eine Liste.
Ich kenn das.
Dann wird man von Tim Armand oder was?
Nee, dann kommst du in so eine Top Ten-Liste von den Leuten, die voll viel Flattergeld haben, aber es nie abgeholt haben.
Bei mir wandert das immer in meinen Flatterpool und die klickt das selber wieder weg.
Das ist doch auch eine Ausgabe, kannst du das sagen.
Aber ich weiß das nicht, ich beobachte das nicht. Ich versuche auch gar nicht darüber nachzudenken, was mein Steuerberater dazu sagt, wenn ich dem davon erzähle.
Mein Steuerberater, meine Steuerberaterin, die hat mir bei der Steuererklärung, ich hatte ja ganz viele Audio-Gadget-Ausgaben, und dann meinte ich, ja, kann ich das nicht auch irgendwie so absetzen? Ja, dann müssten sie halt irgendwie nachweisen, dass sie überhaupt mit diesem Podcasting und Musik-Mann auch Geld verdienen. Und zack, habe ich meinen Flatter hier Auszugs-Dingsbums präsentiert fürs Podcasten. Und dann meinte ich so, ja, alles klar, gut, machen wir hier eine Gewinn-Dingsbums-Rechnung. Und dann durfte ich ein Jahr lang hier mein ganzes Audio-Gezeug nämlich damit schön absetzen. Hat voll was gebracht.
Und gleichzeitig musst du jetzt deinen Flatter-Gewinn versteuern oder wie? Und gleichzeitig musst du jetzt deinen Flatter-Gewinn versteuern oder was?
Ja gut, aber in dem Fall war der Benefit da, sagen wir mal, ja.
Das sind ja wieder krude Rechnungen. Aber gut, jetzt hast du ja genug Zeit, jetzt hast du ja ein Thema dann.
Ach, Themen, das habe ich lieber bewertet.
Ich weiß gar nicht so genau, da steht ja noch so ein Themenblubbel vom letzten Mal. Aber das sind jetzt so random Nerd-Themen. Was interessiert euch denn euch davon? Ich will euch jetzt ja nicht über das von 5% erzählen.
Zu deinem MariaDB da oben, das hört sich ja ganz nerdig an. Da habe ich schon mal eine Frage. Du kannst es dann genauer erklären, aber ich frage trotzdem erst mal so ins Blaue rein. Wenn dein MariaDB auf dem ZFS-Pool läuft, und wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe... Der Hucke wird es gleich genauer erklären. Ich haue mal ins Blaue, habe ich doch gesagt. Ist deine Record-Size von deinem ZFS angepasst an deine MariaDB? Also bei Postgres ist ja 8 Kilobyte und ZFS hat 4. Und dann schiebt man ZFS auch auf 8. Dann sind die in Sync von der Größe und dann ist alles ein bisschen flotter. Hast du es gemacht? So, jetzt darfst du, Hucke.
Also, Kontext, Klammer auf. MariaDB ist ja was, also MariaDB verhält sich zu MySQL wie OpenZFS zu ZFS. Sprich, nachdem...
MariaDB ist eine freie...
Genau....
nicht oragende...
Also der Typ, der MySQL gemacht hat, der hat als Larry the Lawn Mower Ellison kam, hat ja das weitergesucht und hat MariaDB gegründet und macht jetzt MySQL, Drop-in-Replacement-MySQL mit cooleren Features und...
Aber schon auf Basis des alten Codes.
Ja, schon, aber genau, aber er macht jetzt irgendwie...
5.0-Geforkt oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, aber er macht halt coolere Features, die es bei MySQL jetzt sozusagen gar nicht gibt direkt.
Du bist ausgeschaltet. Maria ist halt Monty's jüngere Tochter. Dit Mai heißt nämlich nicht Mai, wie so Mainz oder sowas, sondern es heißt Müh. Das ist der Name seiner ersten Tochter. Maria ist seine zweite Tochter. Hat er noch einen Sohn oder noch ein Kind? Ich weiß nicht, ich müsste mal gucken.
Der ist noch nicht so oft an Müh genannt.
Wie war so klein? Ich verwechsel mal wieder, ob er...
Oder wie mein Physiklehrer gesagt hat, wie machst du eine türkische Kuh?
5 Euro in die Rassismuskasse.
Ich verwechsel mal nicht, ob der schwedischer Finne ist oder finnischer Schwede. Die haben da oben so ein Grenzgebiet, wohnen die immer so gegenseitig irgendwie auf der anderen Seite und so. Einer von denen ist ja, glaube ich, der ist Finne.
Lappe nennt man das dann, glaube ich, oder?
Es gibt auch so unlappige Schweden.
Und man hat ja...
Wie genius klingt der, als ich erst Schwede...
Also hijacken wir das Thema, oder was? Jetzt spreche ich gleich wieder über die Republik.
Wo wir gerade mal Schweden und Finn sind, bevor ich das wieder vergesse. Kennt ihr schon den Wahlwerbespot von Peter Sunde? Also known as Peter from Pirate Bay?
Den müsst ihr euch anschauen.
Der tritt ja für die Piratenpartei Finland jetzt an bei der Europawahl.
Können wir ja nachher noch gucken, oder?
Ihr fallt vom Stuhl.
Ich hab mich nicht eingekriegt.
Das ist wirklich einer der besten ever.
Genau. Das heißt, Wikipedia ist auf MariaDB umgestiegen und es sind schon so ein paar große Leute von MySQL weg und jetzt auf dieses MariaDB. Und wir haben halt bei VUGA so eine fette Datenbank, die wir eigentlich nur noch so für die Data-Analysts da bereithalten, die mit advancederen Datenbanken noch nicht klarkommen und die noch ihr altes, liebes SQL haben wollen. Und da pumpen wir ganz viel Daten rein. Und jetzt hatten wir halt so alles auf FreeBSD mit ZFS umgestellt und das ist erstmal nicht so geflogen, sagen wir mal. Und dann gibt es aber von Oracle Dokumente, wo sie schreiben, ok, pass mal auf, ihr habt einen ZFS und ihr habt einen MySQL, dann müsst ihr folgende Sachen tunen. Und dann halt genau gesagt, hier stellt mal beim ZFS das ein und macht mal dies und das und jenes. Und dann hat er im MariaDB-Channel abgehangen, da war auch tatsächlich ein Typ, der auf FreeBSD 50.000 Insets pro Sekunde hinbekommen hat mit seinem Hobel. Und dann hat unser DB-Typ irgendwie, das geht ja nicht, wir waren ja nur bei 35 und da muss ja noch was gehen und hat dann auch so alle Settings genau mit dem Typen abgeklopft, was hast du, was hab ich und so weiter. Und dann hat er nochmal weitergelesen, in den Oracle Dokumenten gestöbert, was die empfehlen für MySQL und dann am Ende war er bei 65.000 Inserts pro Sekunde und dann irgendwie kam man in den Chat und hat die Krone an sich gerissen und im Prinzip sind das halt so Sachen, dass man zum Beispiel bei ZFS kann man ja pro Volume oder wie sagt man, Dataset? Also kann man unterschiedliche Blockgrößen angeben und im Prinzip, was man bei Postgres und bei MySQL halt macht, im Prinzip haben ja die Datenbanken ganz viele Features implementiert, die jetzt ZFS sozusagen nachgezogen hat. Also die Datenbanken haben ja schon früher Features, die jetzt erst so eigentlich so in moderne Operating Systems so einzugehalten. Und dieses transaktionale Verhalten zum Beispiel von ZFS ist ja jetzt auch erst gekommen. Da kannten Datenbanken schon vorher. Und im Prinzip, wenn du jetzt so ein modernes Fallsystem hast ohne Datenbank, dann kommen die sich sozusagen ins Gehege und du musst sozusagen dem ZFS Volume oder Dataset, wo dein Data Store von der Datenbank ist, den musst du dann halt so ein paar Sachen so ausschalten oder beziehungsweise die mal SQL ein paar Sachen ausschalten, damit die sich nicht so gegenseitig behaken. Und zum Beispiel kann man dann dem ZFS Dataset sagen, hier deine Block-Size ist genauso groß wie die von InnoDB, von der Storage Engine, sodass es dann schon mal beim Schreiben irgendwie da nicht so gerangelt kommt und der nicht unnötig Arbeit hat oder der Datenbank kannst du halt auch sagen, ja pass auf, du musst jetzt hier nicht irgendwie ganz genau auf deinen F-Sync warten und so weiter, weil da ist ein transaktionales Fallsystem, so wenn du committest, dann ist das committed, da musst du nicht noch irgendwie den Daumen drauf halten und so. Und dann kann man sozusagen gegenseitig so ein bisschen die aufeinander so einstimmen und dann fängt es auch an zu fliegen. Und dann haben wir in diesem Mal, also dann hat halt ZFS noch ein paar andere coole Features, halt diesen Read- und den Write-Cache und den Level-2-Read-Cache. Und das haben wir auch online, das ist auch so das geile, wirklich ZFS. ZFS ist so geil, alles online, alle Operationen halt online, du steckst da, die Admins haben halt, wir haben gesagt, wir hätten jetzt gerne noch zwei Intel-SSDs. Und dann hat er...
Ein Tausender-Serie, ne 3700, ne?
Diese Server, die sogar eine MTBF, äh, MTF, MF, BTS oder so. So und der hat die im laufenden Betrieb reingesteckt, also Hotswap war der Server eh fähig, so und dann irgendwie kannst du deinem ZFS sagen, hier pass mal auf, zwei SSDs, hier dein Read und hier dein Write-Cache und bumm, los geht's. Das ist einfach Jolden.
Im laufenden Betrieb.
Im laufenden Betrieb. Ja, auf allen, genau. Und hier ein Kollege von mir, da hat sich ja diesen HP Server, hatte ich ja auch schon mal gesagt, diesen Network Attached Storage und dann hatte er eine SSD, wollte auch reinstecken zum Read-Write-Cache, aber hatte nicht den Rahmen. Und dann hingen die nur an diesem SATA-Connector und irgendwie hat er dann so da rum konfiguriert und dann irgendwie kam immer so eine Meldung ins Log irgendwie, ja, Zill Device weg, Zill Device wieder da, so und dann hat die halt da so einen kleinen Wackler in diesem hängenden, aber das ZFS hat das halt einfach abgemeldet, wenn es nicht da war und wieder angemeldet, wenn es da war, also es lief einfach weiter. Die SSD hat da immer, wenn er auf Klo gegangen ist, irgendwie mal so einen Wackler da gehabt.
War ein Gelegenheits-Cache.
Genau, also aber ja, das funktionierte dann auf jeden Fall ganz gut, ja. Und MariaDB 10 hat auf jeden Fall auch sehr coole Features. Also wäre noch jemand, wenn noch jemand was hier mit Feel und MySQL und so zu tun hat, dann...
Das ist für mich ein interessantes Phänomen, was du gerade beschrieben hast. Dass du sagst, wenn du zwei schlaue Dinge, also transaktionale Datenbank auf ein transaktionales Fallsystem, mit seinen eigenen Optimierungen Cache aufeinanderstöpselst und dann nichts dran machst, dass in der Regel was rauskommt, was schlechter ist als vorher. Das ist ähnlich bei VPNs. Wenn du versuchst irgendwie TCP oder IP über TCP zu tunneln, ist auch nicht so gut. Dabei ist TCP eigentlich besser, weil es Fehlerkorrektur hat und da willst du aber nicht. Dann geht auch eher Sachen kaputt.
Ja, was wollte ich noch gerade sagen? Achso, ich hab ja letztens auch so einen Talk gemacht auf der Ruby User Group. Da hab ich einen Talk gemacht, Introduction to Freebies, DNS, ZFS, weil die hatten irgendwie keine Talks über Ruby und dann hab ich irgendwie gesagt, ja pass auf, ich kann euch mal was von Freebies, DNS erzählen. War auch sehr gut, die sind irgendwie alle dann hinterher noch angelaufen gekommen. Ja, und was kann man da, kann man das auch so machen? Und zwar, das war richtig gut und dann ist mir in der Vorbereitung erst mal aufgefallen, was ja sowieso noch ein richtig krasser Unterschied eigentlich ist zu den anderen Fallsystemen. Also Butterriff S macht das ja so ähnlich, glaube ich, aber ich bin mir gar nicht so gesichert. Bei Linux hast du ja den Logic Volume Manager und das Fallsystem sozusagen separat. Also du kannst mit LVM auf Linux schon sehr viel machen, was theoretisch vergleichbar sein könnte mit Butterriff S oder ZFS, aber es ist halt in der Toolchain ein epischer Hässel, sich das da so zusammen zu stricken. Und ZFS ist halt Logic Volume Manager und Fallsystem in einem und dadurch hast du halt diese zwei Kommandos, die irgendwie alles so super integriert, simpel, online.
Ich meinte doch, dass eine Linux-Coda, dass ZFS so eine Layer Violation wäre, weil die halt einfach das gesamte, alle Layers in ihrer Software haben und das nicht schön sauber durchtrennen, aber dadurch hast du dann halt auch erst die Vorteile, weil sonst könnte das Raid auch nicht die Blöcke reparieren.
Und jetzt noch was, was ich bei der Vorbereitung da gelesen hab. Und zwar gab es einen Talk von einem der ZFS-Typis, der hat seine Slides dann hochgeladen. Der meinte halt so, ja irgendwie 128 Bit Fallsystem, klingt jetzt vielleicht wie Overkill, aber irgendwie ein Petabyte Storage ist irgendwie schon jetzt nicht so exotisch mehr heutzutage und das ist schon 50 Bit. Und Storage Capacity doubled sich alle 9 bis 12 Monate. Das heißt, als wir so ZFS gemacht haben, wollten wir halt in unserer Lebenszeit keinen Stress mehr haben mit wir stoßen an irgendeine Grenze und haben irgendwie sozusagen gleich mal es doppelgenommen, weil sozusagen in 14 weiteren Doppelungen, was noch innerhalb einer Dekade liegen könnte, bist du halt bei 64 Bit sozusagen. Und dann wäre bei Batterie FS schon wieder Schluss.
Ja, ja kann mich auch erinnern von ganz, ganz früher, dass die meinten, dass einige Kunden bei Sun mit ihrer Storage-Größe schon bis an 16 Bits rangekommen sind. An die 64, da sind dann die 50 Bits wahrscheinlich irgendwie so was Vardar macht. Und sie wollten halt schon eins weiter designen. Und du kannst halt nicht nur zwei, drei Bits ranhängen, also verdoppeln. Spielen die alle das gleiche Spiel, nur in groß. Und spielen nicht halt auf mit Teil schieben. 128.
128 Bits ist überhaupt irgendwie eine gute Basis zum Zählen. Wenn man sich sicher sein will, dass man da nicht so richtig ans Ende kommt, dann macht man irgendwie 128 Bits.
War vorhin lustig, auf dem Weg herher hat mich jemand angeschrieben über updote.net oder wie auch immer, ob ich ihm mal 500 IPv6-Adressen verkaufen wollte. Und dann hab ich ihm gerade mal schnell auf dem Taschenreichner ausgerechnet, dass er unter zwei hoch 64 gar nicht an den Start gehen braucht. Und dass er schon von seinem Provider sozusagen zwei hoch 80 geliehen kriegt für Umme, da muss er bei mir mit 500 nicht ankommen. Aber ich glaube, das hat er jetzt noch nicht so gesehen. Aber das ist trotzdem, ist ja dasselbe, weil vor 16 auch 128 Bit. Eben. Das ist jetzt sozusagen jetzt die, das sind jetzt die neuen 64, also das war 64 Bit so vor 20, 25 Jahren für die Leute war so, oh dieses, oh.
Ja 128 ist das neue 64.
Ja, genau.
Ich bin aber, ich muss ja sagen, ich meine, ich weiß ja, also IPv6 und so, jedes Wassermolekül in den Ozeanen kann eine v6 Adresse haben und so. Oder jedes Sandkorn in der Sahara oder irgendwie sowas. Viele. Ja, viele. Aber ich mein, so wie die die Priefixe da rausschleudern, also irgendwie, ich hab bei dem Cluster, was wir da aufgesetzt haben, wir haben da, also die Hälfte von so einer IPv6 Adresse wäre doch.
64.
Genau. Und wir haben noch eins weiter, das ist dann...
Eins weiter meinst du? Eins und einen Block weiter.
Ja, also eins mehr.
Was meinst du, die Hälfte an Bits oder die Hälfte an Adressen? Weil die Hälfte an Adressen wären 127 Bits.
Die kleinste Präfix war so, das ist so vorgesehen, dass die Leute 48 kriegen.
Ja, dann sitzt du da mit deinem, okay, wir haben zwei Racks voll, das sind halt irgendwie, was weiß ich, 30 Server oder 40, lasst es sein.
Na, das war doch Sinn der Sache. Früher hast du halt, bei Pixelpark kann ich mich erinnern, da hat man 10 Netz hier, 10 Netz dort und 10 Netz dort, aber immer natürlich verschiedene Bereiche. Das heißt, das war nicht eine Route, sondern auf jedes 10 Netz, irgendwo, das Slash24 sagt man ja, war da halt eine Route. Mit IPv6 kriegst du halt eine und dann ist Ruhe und dann werden die Routing-Tabellen kleiner. Richtig? Das war eine Idee davon.
Ja, das fühlt sich halt nur so irgendwie... Fühlt sich wasteful an, ne? Jetzt denken sie alle, sie hätten so viel und schleudern hier die Prefaxe raus.
Deswegen ist die Telekom auch ein bisschen sparsamer, weil du bei der Telekom vor 6 kriegst, dann kriegst du auch nur ein Slash56 zugewiesen. Das heißt, du kannst nur 256 Subnetze daraus hinten bauen. Als Endkunde, als DSL-Endkunde meine ich. Also da bist du dann schon ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Na ja, das fixen wir alles mit IPv8 oder so.
Ich will mich jetzt gleich mal mit in die Breche schmeißen, weil der Hucke ja auch so viel von ZFS erzählt hat, wie ich heute festgestellt habe, weil ich gucke immer meine Lieblingsthemen kurz vor der Sendung durch, gibt es von Open ZFS on OS X eine neue Version. Hab ich gar nicht gezwittert. Hab ich gedacht, heute Mittag ich lade die mal runter.
Wie ist denn die Update-Procedure? Einfach drüber installieren?
Ja, hab ich so gemacht. Da stand Punkt DMG heute Mittag. Ich klick das Ding, kommt zu einem kleinen Fenster, ja, nee, Format hier kann ich nicht und so. Hab ich geguckt, hab ich irgendwie Pfeil drüber gejagt. Pfeil sagt, das wäre irgendwie ein XAR. Hab ich es mit tar.xf ausgepackt. Hatte ich da lauter so Packages in meinem Finder liegen. Dachte, ist das so eine Scheiße? Bin ich da in den Open ZFS Channel, meinte ja, hier steht DMG, aber ist irgendwie keins, kann ich nicht ins Thema. Ah ja, Scheiße soll Punkt PKG heißen. Hat da gleich ein neues Release gemacht oder das Ding da geändert. Und ja, jetzt geht's wieder. Also hier.
Gibt's einen Changelog?
Ja, Changelog kannst du auch klicken da. Und die haben da einiges geändert. Ich hab's jetzt mal benutzt. Zumindest tut's so wie vorher. Besser weiß ich nicht, das ist immer noch relativ lahm. Da könnten sie mal ein bisschen was dran machen. Und ich glaub, ein Bug ist, dass der, ähm, wie heißt der? Wie heißt der oben rechts in der Ecke? Der Spotlight, der hört nicht mehr auf, meine ZFS-Platte zu spotlighten. Also, wenn er fertig ist, fängt er sofort wieder von vorne an. Da ist was trauend. Und da müssen wir noch drehen. Aber grundsätzlich, die Jungs sind dabei, die sind am Machen, wenn man bei denen Probleme hat. Die haben Irrchat, da hängen die Leute rum. Also, der Lundmann hat mich direkt selbst versorgt. Und, äh, ja, es ist auch Service. Und hat auch nicht blöde Sprüche gemacht, sondern hat gleich, äh, wirklich auf der Webseite das, äh, den Bild da geändert.
Spricht du jetzt von dem 127RC1?
Genau. Heute Mittag stand da witzigerweise noch 130RC1. Dann hat das geändert, dann mein ich, ey, ist ja jetzt weniger als vorher. Meint da, ja, bei denen, das Releasing, das wär so ein bisschen so wie Lotto, da kommt mal das und mal das raus. Also wahrscheinlich bereiten sie gerade eine 1.3.0 vor und, ja, wie auch immer. Aber die, die, ich hab noch die 1.3.0 auf meinem Rechner, die tut irgendwie, ich denke nicht, dass da groß was anderes ist. Ich denke, die haben nur den Namen da irgendwie geändert und 1.3.0 kommt irgendwie später mit noch mehr Features oder so. Und ich denke immer, die wollen immer gleich ziehen mit diesen Open ZFS on Linux. Und das steht ja auch im Change-Log so drin, dass sie da gleich gezogen sind und deswegen.
Ja, muss ich mal nachher ausprobieren mit meinem tollen ZFS-USB-Stick.
Ja, musst du mal machen.
Ich hab da immer noch das Problem, wenn ich irgendwie boote, dann kommt dann irgendwie immer noch das OS hoch und meint, unreadable, disk, tralala, ignore.
Ja, da ist ja auch ein Ding hier. Wo ist es? Z-Volume Upstream Incompatibility Fixes. Und da steht so ein Sternchen 1 dahinter auf der Webseite, ist da noch ein bisschen mehr Text dazu und zwar das Note, 1.2.0 ZFS Volumes are unintentionally incompatible with other platform version of ZFS except for volume block size gleich 512. Habt ihr das auch, dass ihr mal Englisch lest und die zahlen aber in Deutsch?
Ja, natürlich ist das viel einfacher.
Das ist mir schon bei vielen aufgefallen, dass ich nicht der einzige Idiot bin. Und egal, jedenfalls hat das vielleicht damit zu tun, und du musst mal updaten und zur Not machst du deine Platte mal neu, wenn da noch nicht so viel drauf ist, ich weiß es nicht so genau. Ich hatte ja eine ganz uralte, die von irgendeinem uralt ZFS da, irgendeine uralt Mac-Version erstellt wurde, die geht auch immer noch. Ich hab noch mit diesem open ZFS on OS X noch keine neue Platte gemacht.
Hast du denn noch ein Upgrade drauf gemacht eigentlich?
Also ich hab zwei Olle-Platten mit dem 120 als Mirror mal gemacht. Die liefen dann ohne Probleme und als ich sie abgemeldet hab, hab ich sie nur unter Schmerzen wieder angemeldet gekriegt. Sprich nach einem Reboot hat er sie wieder erkannt.
Da ist auch irgendwas dabei, die haben jetzt dieses Add ZED, ZFS Event Demon to Handle Events, Send Alerts, Emails and Pool Issues. Vielleicht ist das ja so ein Ding, der sich in der Zukunft drum kümmert, dass so Platten auch automatisch wieder hochkommen nach dem Boot und so weiter und so fort. Also, die haben gesagt, sie wollen sich um Fehler kümmern und um Performance erst mal weniger. So sieht's aus eventuell. Müsst ihr mal weiter testen. Und umso mehr Leute da mitmachen. Die haben auch ein Forum, wenn da mal ein paar Einträge kommen, weil am Anfang sah es da ganz schön dünn aus. Da dachte ich mir, alles klar, die ganzen Mac-User, Bunti, Klicki, Maus-Schubser, die interessiert ZFS irgendwie so gar nicht. Aber so langsam nimmt es an Fahrt auf auch nur diesem Forum. Und in dem Org-Channel, da war jetzt auch nicht so wenig los. Da hingen irgendwie so 40, 50 Leute rum. Und er hat ja auch gleich geantwortet. Also er würde nicht antworten, wenn da sonst nichts los ist. Oder er war froh, dass endlich mal einer kam.
Der hat mal eine ordentliche Frage gestellt.
Ich meine, ich glaube, sie haben mir das Image da gestern erst hochgestellt, weil ich dachte mir auch schon, naja, die stellen da irgendwelche Sachen hoch. Man kann das überhaupt gar nicht auspacken und es ist immer noch da. Seit wieviel Tagen liegt das schon da rum? Aber es muss erst letzte Nacht gewesen sein.
Ich hab im Twitter geguckt, als du das getwittert hattest, hab ich bei denen geguckt, ob die was im Feed hatten. Aber nix.
Ich hab was getwittert.
Wer macht da das Release-Management?
Oder irgendwo, du hast irgendwo das, ja, keine Ahnung.
Na der selbst halt noch einfach so.
Ja, wieso gibt es erst eine Version 1.2.0 und die nächste ist 127RC1?
Hallo?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Das sind halt die Developer.
Ich meine, wenn die...
Jetzt ist das mit dem Rendernummer-Generator, mit dem Lotto-Generator.
So hat das gesagt. It's like Lotto.
Verstehe.
You gotta be in it to win it.
Bis wir alles auf 128-Bit umsetzen.
Eine Sache, die mir auch bei meinem kürzlich abgeschlossenen WUGA-Infrastrukturprojekt untergekommen ist, war der Bedarf eines HTTP-Benchmarks. Und jeder, der das schon mal machen durfte, wird wissen, dass es gibt da The Good Old Trustworthy Apache Bench. Ja, das war mit Airquotes. Ihr habt da doch bestimmt alle gehört jetzt hier. Auf Auphonic rennt ihr hoffentlich nicht raus, die Airquotes.
Das weiß man jetzt alles nicht so.
Auf jeden Fall Apache Bench, ja, weiß nicht, sackt irgendwie immer und benutzt halt irgendwie so diese APR-Threading-Library, die halt irgendwie immer Probleme macht, wenn man nicht irgendwie seine System-Limits korrekt konfiguriert hat und es ist einfach Schmerz. Dann gibt es HTTP Perf mit F, nicht mit V, von HP. Und dieses Tool ist so von der Usability, naja, auch nicht so toll. Und es gibt eigentlich immer, also immer Probleme. Und ich hab letztens dann mal wieder gegoogelt, gibt es denn nicht mal was anderes. Und es gibt was anderes, was tatsächlich ganz fluffig ist und das heißt W, R, K, Wrk. Und die Benutzung ist denkbar einfach, also ähnlich wie bei Apache Bench. Und es hat nicht so eine antiquierte Threading Library und funktioniert auf allen US'n und gibt sinnvolle Daten raus. Kein HTTPS, kein Header. Also so für irgendwie mal eben synthetischen Traffic irgendwie auf eine URL pusten und gucken, was da so rumkommt, ob socket Arrows gibt, ob es Timeouts gibt, Latencies.
Und kann der auch ganz viele Connections in der Luft stehen lassen und mit anderen weitermachen? Weil der Nachteil von so einem Benchmark ist ja, der macht immer einen Call, kriegt sofort was und macht den nächsten. Und der AB ist ja auch schon eine Stufe weiter, der kann davon zehn gleichzeitig machen, kriegt die beantwortet, macht den nächsten. Aber im echten Web, ja, da macht einer so einen Call zu der rein, will da irgendwas holen und dann bleibt es einfach stehen. Entweder weil sein DSL gerade abgekackt ist oder warum er, vielleicht bleibt er einfach stehen und Timeout und so und so ein Scheiß muss man halt ständig machen.
Also, in unserem Fall mussten wir HTTPS-Sessions und so schnell und fast und viele und so mal testen. Dafür war das zum Beispiel genau richtig. Wenn du jetzt so eine richtige User-Session testen willst, da gibt es so ein Tool, das ist in Erlangen geschrieben. Zung heißt das. Die Benutzung ist wiederum... Zung? Zung. T-S-U-N-G. Die Benutzung davon ist sehr... Gewöhnungsbedürftig, sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig. So ähnlich, wie wenn man von Ruby nach Erlangen wechselt. Muss man erstmal so ein bisschen... sich so ein Käffchen machen und mal eine ruhige Minute finden. Aber da kann man wirklich... Der hat coole Features, dieser Zung. Da kann man nämlich zum Beispiel Record drücken, den als Proxy sozusagen für seinen Browser einstellen. Drückst du Record und dann kannst du deine Session mal durchklicken. Das wird dann in so einem XML-Format auf was einigermaßen liegsbar ist. Das kann man dann noch mal ein bisschen nachpflegen und generischer machen, dann kann man halt sagen ich will einen Ramp ab so... In den ersten 10 Sekunden sollen 500 Leute kommen, danach alle 10 Sekunden weitere 1000 und die sollen folgende Session klicken und so und so und so. Also mit Zungen kann man dann so was machen. Wer einfach nur mal so blind kurz mal gegenpustet, um zu sehen, ob die Software gleich auseinanderbröckelt, wenn der erste Paketsturm kommt, dann nehmt der AK. Das ist irgendwie dafür auch sehr gut geeignet. Man kann da irgendwie schön sagen, hier Concurrency, wie viel Threads, wie gesagt, für gegenpusten reicht's. Und wo gegen haben wir gepustet? Ha-Proxy haben wir gegen gepustet, denn wir wollten jetzt eben nicht einen teuren Lotbalancer kaufen, um HTTPS selber zu terminieren. Und haben jetzt Ha-Proxy uns außerkorn, weil der hat kürzlich ein anderes Projekt reingemerscht, um HTTPS zu machen, nämlich S-Tunnel. Eines der schönsten Software-Projekte dieses Planeten, so ähnlich wie Warnisch. Warnisch und S-Tunnel, da gab's noch eins. So C-Code, so von alten Hasen geschrieben, der einfach tut, so, der einfach so die Hölle aus deiner Maschine rausperformiert.
Im Makro-Assembler gehackt.
Ja, was auch immer, ja, Mundgepinselt. So und S-Tunnel selber ist aber jetzt auch schon so wieder ein bisschen hinterher. Und jetzt haben die HAProxy-Jungs gesagt, okay, wir mergeln das mal rein. Und da gibt es eine Dev-Version von. Die benutzt zum Beispiel GitHub auch, um sämtlichen HTTPS-Traffic zu terminieren, inklusive den Repo-Traffic. Also wenn du einen Git-Clone auf einen HTTPS-Repo machst, geht das durch eine HAProxy. Und die haben für den gesamten Trafic die acht Maschinen, glaube ich. Und das für GitHub schon nicht so viel eigentlich, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt. Und dann haben wir das halt auch ausprobiert. Ich natürlich auf FreeBSD. Stellt sich gleich erstmal raus. Die Jungs sind halt Linux-Entwickler. Die haben irgendwie so eine P-Thread-Shared-Log benutzt, was es nur auf Linux ab Körner XY gibt. Sprich, es gab eine Infinite Loop oder einen Core-Dump-Wahlweise. Haben sich aber sofort bei der Ehre gepackt gefühlt und haben es gefixt. Und dann gab es noch ein Problem mit Core-Dumps. Und das war Linux und FreeBSD, also auf allen Plattformen bestehend. Und das habe ich zum Beispiel auch mit diesem Gegenpust mit dem BRK nicht hinbekommen. Das ging nur mit Live-Traffic, hat sich dieser Core-Dump dann aufgetan. Wie immer. Aber das ist jetzt auch gefixt und jetzt läuft es. Gerade in diesem Moment schaue ich aufs Terminal. Also seit 12 Stunden läuft jetzt der hAProxy durch. Vorher hat er immer nur noch...
Der hat den Peak jetzt schon überlebt?
Genau, der hat den Peak schon überlebt.
Du machst das jetzt mit einer Kiste? Mit einer echten oder einer virtuellen?
Nur echte Kisten.
Okay, ich sorge dir jetzt mal ein paar Zahlen. Bei wie viel CPU machst du wie viele Sessions mit wie viel Schweiß?
Also es ist eine 12-Core-Maschine. 12-Core Xeon mit so 2,3, irgendwie so 2,4 Gigahertz pro Core oder sowas. Ich glaube die Mehrcore-Maschinen haben ja nicht so viel, die günstigen Xeons jedenfalls nicht. 32 Gigagramm und auf jeden Fall sind gerade 11.000 Sockets offen und Current Connections sind 500x, 510x, 6.000 Sessions sind da gerade offen und pro Sekunde kommen 12x 130 dazu. 12x 130 sind dann 1500 Sessions pro Sekunde, also Connections.
Neue Sessions oder welche, die weiter gemacht werden?
Ne, neue, aber die sind sehr kurz, lebe ich alle nur.
Was hast du da für einen Link dran? Nur ein Gig?
Also wir machen, Traffic ist gerade wirklich sehr wenig, 2 MB die Sekunde. Also es geht nur um so mal eine URL abgeben und ein Tracking-Gift zurückkriegen, ne? Aber ja, und die Kiste ist bei einer Load von 2 bis 2,5 Grad. Und HAProxy hat auch seit ein paar Versionen jetzt so ein Feature, dass man, früher war das halt Single-Threaded, mit einem Prozess, und jetzt kannst du halt sagen, hier forkt man noch ein paar Worker und jetzt laufen halt 12, also pro Core einer. Und benutzt halt OpenSSL mit dieser AIS-NE-Extension, wo man eben Hardware-Beschleunigungen bekommt für Cipher, die AIS benutzen. Dann sagt man halt in seinem HAProxy, ja guten Tag, ich hätte gern die vor allen Dingen gerne. Und mit dieser Hardware-Beschleunigung kriegt man eben dann so zwei bis dreimal mehr Performance als ohne. Wobei man sagen muss, OpenSSL 9.8, das was jetzt so wahrscheinlich immer noch als das stable OpenSSL gilt, so mehr oder weniger. Wenn man von 0.9.8 auf 1.0.1 geht, kriegt man schon einen wahnsinnigen Performance Boost. Und wenn man dann noch dieses AIS-NE anmacht, beziehungsweise den OpenSSL in den letzten Versionen ist das automatisch an. Wenn eine CPU das kann, dann kriegt man eben noch mal zwei bis dreimal mehr Durchsatz. Und damit braucht man eigentlich heutzutage nicht mehr diese Hardware-Load-Balancer, weil die früher, oder die hatten halt immer diese ASIC-Boards, so ähnlich wie Dennis für seine Bitcoins, so eine Special-Purpose-Chips, die für einigen für diese AIS-Krypto schnell waren. Und deswegen waren diese Hardware-Load-Balancer halt voll toll, aber mittlerweile sind die modernen CPUs schnell genug, um das sozusagen zu kompensieren. Dann macht man eben statt vielleicht sechs Cores vielleicht zwölf oder 24 Cores rein.
Unsäglich teuer. Die sind schon ohne SSL-Acceleration, die sind schon unsäglich teuer. Und dann nochmal allein die Lizenz bei F5, wie für SSL oder sonst irgendwas, bei so einem mittelgroßen Load-Bancer, ist auch schon wieder fünfstellig. Darüberreich interessant, nicht mit einer Eins vorne. Also von daher...
Hier sagt gerade einer, ich sage Engine X, ja Engine X kann das im Prinzip auch, aber Engine X ist erstens nicht primär ein Proxy und da drin auch nicht super gut. Und ein SSL-Proxy kann er auch, aber ist auch da nicht besonders gut. Also zum Beispiel S-Tunnel gegen Engine X, da stinkt der Engine X oder also sagen wir mal das letzte Mal, als ich es getestet habe oder geschaut habe, was vom Jahr, da hat der Engine X noch vergleichsweise abgestunken, weil es halt auch nicht seine Primärdomäne ist. Der kann zwar mittlerweile auch viel und das finde ich auch nicht so unbedingt gut, weil der Engine X eigentlich auch geil war, weil der so eine Sache gut kann.
Der kann schon zu viel, ne?
Der kann jetzt langsam zu viel, der kann es jetzt lua drin ausführen und also das ist schon nicht gut. Und ja, also S-Tunnel war halt so ein Special-Purpose-Tool nur um SSL zu terminieren, war da drin richtig gut und HA-Proxy im Proxying richtig gut und jetzt auch so dieser Merge ist natürlich jetzt auch schon wieder so ein bisschen gefährlich, sag ich mal, aber momentan performt er einfach extrem gut und hat auch sehr viele Optionen, um dieses Proxying und SSL-terminieren-Fight zu tunen.
Sie mussten das aber machen. Alle Welt, jede scheiß Kreti-Pleti-Webseite geht jetzt auf HTTPS. Du kannst sonst mit der HA-Proxy, könnte sonst mittelfristig einpacken, wenn er nicht ordentlich ist.
Sehr varnisch, dass er wirklich auch so ein Tool ist, was einfach so Performance-Probleme lösen kann.
Da hat er geschrieben SSL, da ist zwar die Finger von.
Genau, das macht er nicht rein. Hatten wir glaube ich auch die UL mal gepostet in diesem Artikel.
Da hat er aus einem längeren Bericht geschrieben.
Aber irgendwo muss es halt terminieren und dein HA-Proxy ist natürlich jetzt erstmal eigentlich schon der richtige Ort dafür. Und wie gesagt, bei NGINX gibt es halt nicht so viele Feintuning-Optionen, um da wirklich die volle Performance rausholen. Deswegen würde ich für so eine Sachen tatsächlich immer nicht NGINX nehmen.
Der Lite-TTPD oder wie er heißt, der war ja auch mal relativ light, aber inzwischen ist das ja auch ein riesengroßes Ding. Und dann dachte ich mir, den nehme ich auch nicht und habe jetzt meinen Web-Server auch auf NGINX umgestellt.
Die Config von NGINX ist halt auch super. Die kann man ja tatsächlich lesen und fast nachts noch halb besoffen mit drei Bier-Infos noch schreiben, ohne sich zu fangtun. Aber man kann für kleine Sachen auch NGINX nehmen. Das ist jetzt ein Viertel von unserem eigentlichen Traffic, den wir da gerade zum Testzwecken drauf lassen. Das wird noch mal vier, was ich dir gerade gesagt habe. Genau. Wenn jetzt der nicht Chor dummt über Nacht und so weiter, dann kommt auch noch eine zweite als Hot-Failover-Standby, wie auch immer, mit dazu. Damit habe ich mich so beschäftigt, während ihr auf der Republik war.
Auch schön.
Und, ja, das waren ganz viele lehrreiche Lektionen. Eine, die mich auch immer wieder so begleitet ist, immer wenn man denkt, irgendeine Software ist schuld, dass es nicht performt, zum Beispiel, das liegt jetzt am FreeBSD, dass irgendwas komisch ist, oder es liegt jetzt am HAProxy, dass das irgendwie abkackt. Außer die Corelamps, die lagen natürlich wirklich am HAProxy. Aber meistens ist dann doch so die eigene Konfiguritis, dass man irgendwelche Optionen einschaltet, die man nur so halb versteht oder irgendwie noch drin lässt, oder die nach dem Reboot wieder aktiv sind, weil man die nur so on the fly ausgeschaltet hat, um mal was auszuprobieren. Und so war es zum Beispiel bei uns auch. Es lief alles super und dann war halt so ein Core-Dump. Und irgendwie dachte ich, okay, ich reboot mal die Kiste, damit alles wieder super ist und alles clean state und alle Counter resetted, damit man noch mal schön gucken kann. Und es ging alles überhaupt nicht. Sobald der Traffic drauf kam, waren die Backends offline, Layer 4 Probleme und irgendwie, ich hab die Welt nicht mehr verstanden und schon alles verflucht und verteufelt, wollte schon Linux aufsetzen. Nein, so schlimm war es nicht, Dennis. Ganz wieder beruhigt, dich zurücklehnen. Und dann stellte sich halt raus, dass nach dem Reboot war halt Packetfilter wieder an und ich hab halt nicht so die...
Du hast den nur disabled, aber nicht den aus dem ETC-Links rausgenommen.
Genau, und weil der halt nicht so für viel Traffic konfiguriert war, hat der dann erstmal die Pakete gefressen und die Connections zerstört und ja, da war irgendwie...
Ja, bei dem PF, also wir reden ja von dem Packetfilter-PF auf FreeBSD, der hat halt per Default schon seit einer Weile ist der State voll und wenn du da so viele Connections hast, dann musst du glaube ich die Default-States von 10.000 oder so, musst du natürlich ein bisschen hochschrauben, sonst geht dann nicht viel. Weil jede Connection, die nämlich zum Beispiel halb offen bleibt oder einfach nur so da irgendwo abgestorben ist und da so rumhängt, nimmt dir halt ein State weg und irgendwann ist halt voll. Aber da kannst du mit PF-Control, Minus S, Minus A oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung, kannst du die da alle sehen und dann schraubst du einfach hoch.
Ja, wenn jetzt hier erstmal diese H-Aproxy da durchschwurbelt, dann ist das schon die nächste Baustelle. Aber es war auch so ganz cool, weil der hat halt gesagt, so ja, oh scheiße, hier irgendwie Core-Dump ist ja gar nicht gut und was könnte das sein? Und dann habe ich mich ja mal in Sphären begeben, so aus meinem Elfenturm abgestiegen und ein GDB gestartet und ein Core-Dump, Backtrace rausgebremdet.
Ihr baut euer Zeug da gar nicht mit LLVM?
Ey, Linux-Entwickler, die so mit GNU-Make und so bauen halt, ne?
Aber euer Freebizte ist doch mit LLVM?
Ja, aber...
Gibt's da dann kein LLDB?
Ja, aber wir haben ja den H-Aproxy auch mit GMake gebaut, mussten wir leider, und dann halt keine Debugging-Symbols und erst mal rausfinden, wie man Debugging-Symbols anmacht und detailliert. Ja. Ja, ordentlich was dazugelernt bei diesem Infrastrukturprojekt so über Daten, Banken, File-Systeme, Proxys, SSL-Terminierungen.
Was machst du eigentlich, wenn das fertig ist?
Ich bin leider schon damit fertig.
Blöd.
Na, weil, also ich bin noch nicht fertig, aber ich muss schon wieder das nächste machen, weil das sind so Sachen drin, ne? Also wir haben jetzt so voll das fette Cluster und das hat Headroom ohne Ende und dann benutzen die da so Software, wo da so der ganze Headroom hinter so einem kleinen, so einem kleinen Türspäron quasi irgendwie sich noch verstecken muss, ja. Und da könnte man, also da müsste man mal, ne? Zum Beispiel haben die halt in JRuby, die, also das ist ja auch kein Vorwurf, die sind halt nicht so weit hinten normalerweise zugegen, die machen halt eher Applikationen, die da jetzt hauptsächlich die Infrastruktur nutzen. Und die haben halt in JRuby, weil sie halt Ruby toll finden, aber ein bisschen mehr Performance wollen, irgendwie sich so Daten verarbeitende Programme geschrieben. Und dann so die Infrastruktur eingestellt, mussten halt so ein bisschen Backlog aufholen und wir haben Gigabit oder sogar 10 Gigabit, ja. Und dann macht das so 5 Megabyte die Sekunde und die CPU auf allen Kernen ist auf Anschlag. Und dann haben wir mal eins von diesen Tools mal in Erlang geschrieben und das war, die Kiste war bei einer Load von 1,2, hat 95 MB die Sekunde da durchgesaugt auf dem Gigabit Link oder sogar ein bisschen schneller teilweise. Und so muss das sein. Und da gibt es noch so ganz viele Baustellen jetzt leider.
Das heißt, du musst jetzt noch auffegen?
Ich würde gerne, aber ich darf nicht. Das müssen jetzt die Nächsten machen. Die dürfen jetzt auf dieses bestellte Feld, wo jetzt aber noch so ganz viele Abenteuerspielplätze drauf sind. Nerd-Abenteuerspielplätze, da dürfen sich jetzt andere austoben.
Geil, Duschraum gebaut für irgendwie 150 Duschen und dann merkt man, dass die Zuleitung nur ein Gartenschlauch mit Wasser ist.
Naja, aber mit dem Load Balancer darf ich mich jetzt noch so nebenbei ein bisschen beschäftigen.
Da ist mir jetzt auch gerade ein neuer Metadatentyp eingefallen, den wir so in unsere Podloft haben dann einbauen müssen in Zukunft. Target Audience.
Target Audience.
Nerd Level.
Genau.
Schreibst du deine Treiber noch mit cutgroßerdriver.o?
Ja, wir müssen...
Ich muss mir meinen Pulli ausziehen. Oder das Fenster aufmachen. Ich hab mich in der Rage geredet. Das ist gut.
Amkele ist jetzt warm.
Betriebstemperatur erreicht. Jetzt geht's los, schnallt euch an.
Ja, ich bin auf Betriebstemperatur.
So, ich will jetzt wieder.
Du willst schon wieder, oder?
Du hast doch die Republik KDS die ersten 1,5 Stunden verraten.
Was ist eigentlich mit Bulleck? Ah, macht ihr mal euren Karten.
Tim will auch mitspielen, sonst schläft er ein.
Ich mach kurz Pause, kein Problem.
Wir müssen ja noch über Abdottnet reden. Was ich noch erwähnen wollte, ich hab's schon getweetet, das dauert jetzt auch gar nicht so lange, und zwar für jeden, der einen Mac Pro hat, einen haben will, einen gerne gehabt, hätte mal irgendwann oder irgendwie so, oder sich überlegt, ob er sich den neuen die Tonne holt. Da gibt's einen schicken Guide, wie soll man die url, ist halt eine url, pindelski.org/photography/technical slash Mac minus Pro slash.
Ja, die url, die pimpt man in den Chat.
Ich schmeiß die mal da rein, genau.
Und dann kommen die in die Show Notes, wie durch ein Wunder.
Genau, und dann könnt ihr da mal klicken. Na dann, jetzt ist das noch nicht der Link direkt, oder? Ich mach das mal hier so direkt.
So.
Jedenfalls dort, der Typ hat alles gesammelt, was man mit seinem Mac Pro so machen kann. Also von USB-Aufrüsten, von Firmware-Upgraden, was Tim ja auch gemacht hat und ich auch schon letztes Jahr. Von den CPUs, die man sich da umbauen kann und ob es was bringt und ob es nichts bringt. Wobei ich finde, da könnte er noch ein bisschen genauer sein, aber nun gut. Und wenn Welches RAM man reinsteckt, was man machen muss, damit es auch mit dem entsprechenden Speed erkannt wird, also hier dieses 1333 MHz und alles mögliche und ganz am Ende ist auch noch so eine ganz, ganz kleine Abteilung für die neue runde Tonne, weil selbst dort kann man ja auch die CPU wechseln schon. Wenn man nicht die teure Apple Option nehmen will, dann kauft man sich nämlich die kleine Tonne und bestellt sich irgendwie sonst so die ganz dicken Intel CPUs und baut die da selber ein. Wenn man sich traut, dann spart man da auch irgendwie ein paar Tausend Dollar. Das kann man alles machen, das steht alles auf diesen auf diesen mehreren Seiten von diesem Typen und das ist einfach nicht nur da hingeklatscht, sondern er zählt auch ein bisschen drumrum und es liest sich auch spaßig, werden auch leicht arrogant, aber das macht vielleicht auch den Spaß aus. Und da sollte man mal gucken, wenn man Mac Pro hat. Auch wenn man vielleicht gar nichts vorhat, weil manche Sachen sind wirklich so einfach, dass man es einfach machen kann. Zum Beispiel Firmware-Updaten, weil dann hat man... Was war der Unterschied? Ich glaube, man hat, wenn man die richtige Grafikkarte hat und die sind ja die Standard-Apple-Grafikkarten, dann hat man auch ein neues Audiovis über den HDMI-Ausgang der Grafikkarte. Einfach nur durch so ein Firmware-Update. Und der erklärt da alles ganz ordentlich.
Eine Lektion, auf jeden Fall, die ich auch schon nicht nur bei diesem Projekt gelernt habe, übrigens mit dieser Infrastruktur. BIOS-Updaten, immer eine ganz tolle Idee. Hat mir noch nie geschadet, hat immer eigentlich mehr Features freigeschaltet, so dass plötzlich irgendwie mehr größere Platten funktionieren oder plötzlich irgendwelche Dinge funktionieren, plötzlich die vorher nicht funktioniert haben. Und IPME-Firmware-Updaten, das ist auch ein ganz toller Task, wenn ihr einen Server irgendwo habt und da gibt es ein IPME-Interface.
Dann hängt es nicht ins Public-Netzwerk.
Und wenn es, und wenn er es müsste, weil es nicht anders geht, dann updatet wenigstens die Firmware, weil...
Ich gehört aber, dass IPME so offen wie ein Scheinentor, man sollte nicht ins Public-Internet hängen.
Aber manche Provider erlauben es dir halt nicht, oder es ist halt nicht vorgesehen. Und dann solltest du wenigstens mal die Firmware updaten, weil zum Beispiel machen die auch so was wie die speichern das Passwort im Cleartext. Und da gibt's jetzt so, weil Supermicro gab's ein Update, wo dann irgendwie, ja, wir verschlüsseln jetzt übrigens auch mal die Passworte ab. Aber das IPME-Interface ist trotzdem ohne HTTPS erreichbar. Aber ja, also, naja, auf jeden Fall BIOS updaten, IPME updaten, das kann echt Freude ins Gebäude bringen. Und eine kleine Ergänzung noch zum Schluss. Wer wissen, wer will, warum der Aproxy auf allen Plattformen gequadampt hat, packe ich hier den Komit in die Show Notes, wo sogar mir gedankt wird, dass ich da hier fleißig Live Traffic Test-Banee für ihn gemacht habe und Stack Traces generiert habe. Da war ich ganz stolz. Aber irgendwie bei diesen C-Jungs, ne? Also ich komme ja aus einer Welt, wo Code getestet wird und so. Und der hat mir halt dann so Mails geschrieben, so ja, Stack Traces, so. Und dann halt ein paar Minuten später oder halbe Stunde später kommt so eine Mail, ja ich glaube ich hab's gefunden durch Code lesen und hier ist ein Patch und applyt ihn mal und sagt mir, ob's geht.
Er hat da kein FreeBSD-Win-Gap oder was?
Ja, ne, das war jetzt ja plattformunabhängig, den ich da gepostet hab oder...
Der dachte, du brauchst den fixen ganz, ganz geschwind oder ist auch nicht so easy mit so einem Test mal so eine Live-Welt nachzubauen oder so.
Aber sowas wie z.B. kommt ein neues Release raus, hat da was an der Konfig geändert, das verbessert auch. Ich hab ne funktionierende Konfig, ich installier das neue Release, das Ding coredumpt beim Konfig-Parsen. Und ich mein ja, so ja, ich komm aus einer anderen Welt, aus einer anderen Zeit, aus einer anderen Schule, aber ist das wirklich so? Ich meine, muss das sein? Das gibt mir so ein bisschen extra Thrill, wenn ich so Software benutze.
C ist halt so wie so ein Auto ohne Türen, ohne Scheibe, ohne Got, ohne Airbag. Das ist halt, wenn du da einen Unfall machst, dann bist du halt so platt wie nix.
Man nennt es auch Motorrad, ne? Eben, C auch.
Das ist ein guter Vergleich, das muss ich mir mal merken.
C ist wie Motorradfahren, ne? Und so was wie Ruby ist dann hier so ein Google Car, was von alleine fährt, oder was? Aber da gab es ja auch eine schöne Fragestellung, ne? Wenn jetzt dein Auto autonom fährt, und da ist jetzt irgendwie die Wahl, entweder das Auto fährt dich in den Graben und macht dich tot, oder es fährt die zwei Leute, die gerade über die Straße laufen, nachts um und lässt dich am Leben, ne? Also wo, wie sollte das Auto entscheiden, ne? Das sind jetzt auch wieder so ganz neue moralisch-ethische Fragestellungen.
Naja, ich würde mal sagen, es kommt drauf an, wem die AI gehört, oder?
Ob du das für das Selbstschuss-Upgrade irgendwie bezahlt hast. Na, da gab es irgendwie so in letzter Zeit oder in den letzten Tagen ein paar so Tweets, wo es um so eine Fragestellung ging. Aber das mit diesem, wem soll ich totfahren, das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante, ja. Aber da hat doch auch nichts weiter zu zu sagen, ne? Da wollen wir erst gar nicht hin.
Wir sind noch nicht zum Ethikgrad aufgestiegen.
Das fast machen wir nicht auf.
Sonst kommt hier gleich das nächste Sendegate.
Aber wir können da kurz diskutieren, wenn du willst. Also meine Idee ist, angenommen das Beispiel, das du geben hast, da laufen zwei über die Straße, die machen was falsch und deine AI sagt, ok, eigentlich müsste ich ja jetzt in den Graben fahren, dann wäre der Fahrer tot. Das ist besser, als wenn die zwei sterben. Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber den Langzeitfaktor beachten. Und zwar haben die beiden ja was falsch gemacht. Und damit das den Leuten bewusst ist, dass wenn sie was falsch machen, zu Not auch überfahren werden, muss man sie auch überfahren, sonst lernen die Leute nichts. Sonst gehen die ja weiterhin immer wieder über die Straße und dann sterben immer wieder Leute, die in den Rand fahren müssen und dann gekäht werden, anstatt die beiden, die falsch über die Straße laufen. Also muss man die einmal überfahren, damit die anderen lernen, dass sie es nicht tun, und dann stirbt nämlich keiner mehr.
Die David-Subroutine.
Man darf nicht nur den Einzelfall betrachten, sondern muss das auf die Länge sehen.
Entschuldigung, wir mussten sie aus bildungspolitischen Gründen umbringen.
Korrekt.
Ne, ne, ne, aus evolutionären Gründen.
Ja, die Darwin-korrekte Entscheidung.
Genau, die Darwin-korrekte Entscheidung.
Das hab ich bei meinem Pool auch gemacht, beim Bitcoin-Pooling. Da gibt es so Sachen, die Leute geben falsche Shares ab und die Pools denken sich alles klar, die kriegen das trotzdem belohnt, weil das ist besser, als wenn die weggehen und ihre Miner woanders rechnen lassen, weil sie sonst invalid Shares sehen. Und die User sehen nicht gerne invalid Shares. Ich hab das nie gemacht, weil ich dachte mir, fuck, wenn die was falsch abgeben, dann kriegen die nichts bezahlt, weil die müssen lernen, dass sie das halt nicht machen sollen. Sondern wenn ich die einmal bezahle, obwohl es falsch ist, dann machen das alle so irgendwann und dann gibt es irgendwann nur noch defekte Shares und Zeug. Und deswegen mach ich das nicht und da bin ich hart geblieben. Ist mir egal. Vielleicht ist deswegen mein Pool auch so scheiße und so klein, aber ist mir schon gut.
Aber dafür Arten rein.
Evolutionär korrekt.
Zumindest wird nichts angenommen, was so nicht okay ist. Da gibt es halt noch ordentliche Fehlermeldungen. Die sollen dann gucken und sollen das halt irgendwie fixen.
Ja, hier werden schwerwiegende Entscheidungen getroffen, die das wohl alle beeinflussen. Zum Besten natürlich.
Genau, wir retten die Evolution.
Mit Lebertran.
Die kommt nämlich alleine nicht klar. Die schwächelt.
Ja, die schwächelt auf jeden Fall.
Die schwächelt.
So, das war jetzt eine kurze Runde mit dem Mac Pro. Du hast ja Mac Pro, ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich hab ja heute diesen neuen Mac Pro das erste Mal gesehen. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so viel Zeit verstreichen lassen von einem Release einer neuen Hardware bis ich die...
Doch, beim iPhone.
Nein, das hab ich zumindest mal gesehen.
Ja, Jahre später.
Wie Jahre später?
Hat doch voll ewig gedauert.
Wann kam das raus?
2007.
Nein, wann kam das genau raus?
Juni 2007.
Also in Deutschland gab es das ja erst ein Jahr später, so ging es ja schon mal los.
Nee, kein Jahr später. Ein Jahr später. Im Dezember gab es das dann schon, aber ich glaube es kam erst im November raus, kann das sein? Oktober, November?
Ja, schon eine Weile später.
Ja, aber zwei Monate später habe ich definitiv schon mal eins in der Hand gehabt.
Solange gibt es die Mac Pros jetzt auch noch nicht, die Tonnen.
Na, ein halbes Jahr gibt es die jetzt.
Wer hoffste. Da hat Apple gesagt, ja, wir liefern jetzt mal drei aus an, irgendwie.
Menschen hatten Zugriff auf diese Geräte, ich sage nur...
Ja, Apple Mitarbeiter.
Also du hast jetzt da und hast an einem geleckt.
Und?
Ist gleich die Alarmanlage losgegangen, wie du es vorhin gesagt hast.
Ist gleich die Alarmanlage losgegangen.
Hat es performt.
Ich konnte das jetzt nicht groß testen in dem Moment. Ich habe da ein bisschen rumgeklickt und mir das angeschaut, aber es ist halt... Ich weiß nicht.
Hast du die denn mal rumdrehen lassen? R2D2-mäßig, blau leuchtend. Weiß.
Ja, da gehen halt die Lampen an und zeigen mir halt all diese ganzen blöden Stecker, wo ich all dieses ganze Gebimsel dran stecken kann. Und genau so verhält sich das auch. Allein schon wie das Ding so demonstrationstechnisch da auf dem Tisch steht, mit diesem Bondage-Appliance da hinten dran. Also das ist ja wirklich wie so ein... Was ist denn so, beim Bondage, da gibt es auch immer so ein Grut übers Maul, wo du so eine Kugel im Mund hast. Entschuldigung, ich hab jetzt nicht so aus der Erfahrung heraus...
Das eine ist doch nicht irgendwie Seilen, das was... Das Gag-Ball ist doch ein Gag-Ball. Nicht, dass ich mich da aufkenne, aber...
Was soll ich sagen, ich bin nach wie vor kein Freund von Geräten, die jetzt künstlich kleingehalten werden, damit man dann hinten all das anschließt, was man sowieso haben will, was man ja auch gleich hätte reinbauen können, wenn halt nur der Platz da gewesen wäre. Das finde ich ja so toll an diesem Mac Pro, dass das Teil da unten steht. Ja, also am alten Mac Pro, genau an meinem Mac Pro. Das ist so quasi mein kleines Rechenzentrum. Und das geht halt nicht. Ich meine mir ist schon klar, warum das so ist und la la la und der Trend und die Zukunft und all das und so und sicherlich und die Leute, die diese Büchse jetzt wirklich brauchen, die stellen sich da...
Und sicherlich und sowieso.
Du weißt, dass du da Goldstaub unterm Tisch hast, ja?
Ja, weiß ich.
Weil du hast da die Dual Xeon Variante, die du wirklich...
From my cold dead hands.
Ja, du kannst den aufrüsten, dann ist der schnellste Neuer. Wirklich.
Du hast ja gerade rezitiert.
Und ehrlich gesagt, mir reicht auch diese Performance von diesem Teil. Massig aus. Also es gibt wirklich nichts, außer jetzt hier Final Cut, wo durchrennen und so weiter.
Außer hier und außer da.
Ja, aber dann kann ich halt auch mal eine Stunde warten oder so. Da bringt es mir jetzt auch nicht, dass es dann 30% schneller ist. Das bringt es nicht. Aber das ist auch gar nicht so der Punkt. Also ich weiß, dass Leute, die jetzt quasi die Kernzielgruppe sind, das sind wahrscheinlich alles so Leute, die einfach, die brauchen einfach die nackte Performance, also die rohe lokale nackte Performance am Pixel. Aber die haben halt so Storage und solche Sachen, die stehen halt drei Räume weiter. Da gehen irgendwo Glasfaserkabel und da geht da irgendwie ein oder zehn Gigabit Netzwerk rüber.
Zehn Gigabit Ethernet wäre noch schick, aber hat sie auch nicht, richtig?
Ja, aber da kannst du zehn Gigabit anstecken.
Gibt es auch schon?
Weiß ich nicht.
Kennst du irgendjemand, der das hat?
Naja, aber auch, ich weiß nicht, ob es das schon gibt, wird es auf jeden Fall geben. Ich meinte, davon gelesen zu haben, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Aber Ethernet hat er doch direkt.
Ja, aber auch mit Gigabit Ethernet, wenn du dahinter schnellen Netzwerk-Storage hast, der auch delivert.
Aber über das Gigabit gehen nur 100 MB rüber.
Also für Videodateien zum Beispiel.
Meine lokale Festplatte ist schneller als 100 MB.
Das ist schon nicht so schnell, tatsächlich, für so große Datenmengen, also für Audio und Video, ist das total schnarchelangsam.
Ja, aber du musst sie vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer so super Realtime-mäßig haben, sondern musst sie halt wie auch immer. Ich bin ja auch nicht diese Zielgruppe. Ich bin mir nur sicher, es gibt eine, und die ist das sicherlich toll, aber ich gehöre halt nicht dazu, und von daher ist für mich das Ding irgendwie nüscht, und irgendwie ist es ja auch immer noch teuer und sieht irgendwie dann nüscht aus. Also es glänzt halt so komisch, ich weiß nicht, wenn er mal wenigstens ordentlich schwarz wäre, aber das ist ja so völlig fair. Der ist irgendwie nix, also er hat irgendwie keine Farbe, dieses Teil, das ist irgendwie so...
Man hat Fingerabdrücke ganz schnell.
Ja, und will sich irgendwie nicht so richtig...
Die sah auch aus, wenn man oben irgendwie den Arm fasst.
Ja, nee, aber der ist ja nun der Lüfter, aber mich erinnert das halt sehr an diesen Cube. Und der Cube und ich, wir waren echt keine Freunde.
Der hatte wenigstens nur Ecken und Kanten.
Ja, dann merkte dieses Mac Pro Pimpin Guide, da ist alles drin, um deine Kiste noch ein paar Jahre am Leben zu erhalten.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich braucht dem Neue deutlich weniger Strom.
Bevor du sie weg gibst, ich will die Dual-CPU-Karte da haben.
Ich geb hier überhaupt nix weg.
Ich frage in 20 Jahren nochmal.
Ja, ich komm mir mittlerweile echt alt vor, weil gerade was das Apple-Universum betrifft, ich kotze.
iOS 6, iPhone 4, Mac Pro, alles alter Stuff.
Ja, ich hab hier auch mein altes, hier das letzte seiner Art MacBook Pro noch irgendwie mir schnell geschnappt, bevor es nur noch klassisch kommt.
Jedes Software von Apple, die ich aktiv benutze, ist mittlerweile in einer neuen Version rausgekommen, wo das Feature, was ich am meisten benutze, nicht mehr drin ist. Numbers ist nicht mehr benutzbar, Pages ist nicht mehr benutzbar, Keynote ist für mich nicht mehr benutzbar, alles.
Das war doch so langsam, dass man das beim Pouten machen musste.
Ja, aber es hatte zumindest coole Features.
Die haben sie jetzt entfernt. Schneller ist die neue Version auch nicht. Ist das schneller?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's nicht mehr benutzt danach.
Ich kann's nicht testen, weil das eine Feature war halt langsam und das hätte ich jetzt gerne mal schnell gehabt. Aber stattdessen haben sie es halt komplett entfernt. Geil! So, das heißt, diese ganze iWorks-Shoot, die taugt mir schon mal gar nicht. Mal gucken jetzt irgendwie nächste...
iMovie finde ich auch irgendwie eine ganz schöne Katastrophe in der Benutzung.
Das habe ich jetzt schon länger nicht mehr...
Sei froh!...
und hab die auch noch nie so richtig benutzt.
Also Logic Pro X finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Gerrit Spendt haben sie ja auch das Podcast-Feature rausgenommen. Hab ich zwar jetzt auch nicht mehr so benutzt, aber ist auch so ein Opfer. Also jede Software-Release von irgendeiner Applikation von Apple killt irgendwas, was ich geil finde.
Also ich würde sagen, Final Cut und Logic sind tatsächlich sogar besser geworden. Aber die ganzen Consumer-Apps eher nicht. Wobei ich habe jetzt Keynote für den Rugby, also User Group Talk auch mal wieder benutzt. Und ich habe Keynote nie mit irgendwelchen Fancy-Features benutzt. Ich musste da einfach nur Slides machen und hier Rehearsal Mode und fertig. Und das war auch schnell und snappy und das hat getan. Und hat auch hier, was ich sehr schön fand, dieses automatische Anpassen auf die Resolution, dass du nicht mehr irgendwie vorher dir das auswählen musst. Das war alles super, von daher hatte ich da jetzt keinen Schmerz. Das hat tatsächlich intuitiv direkt so funktioniert, wie ich das benutzen wollte, aber...
Nee, sie nehmen auch nur meine Features drauf. Also ich benutze zum Beispiel den alten Keynote. Es gibt ja immer diese Animation, dass du sagen kannst, wie erscheinen die Dinger drauf. Und es gibt da unter anderem auch die Animation. Das Feature als solches existiert auch nach wie vor. Das ist, wenn du so eine Bulletlist hast, dass du die halt Klick für Klick revealen kannst. Weil ich das immer hasse, wenn man so einen Slide präsentiert mit mehreren Punkten, dass die alle auf einmal kommen, weil dann nämlich alle Leute anfangen, alle Punkte zu lesen, auch wenn du noch über den ersten redest und überhaupt nicht weißt, was Sache ist.
Das gibt's nicht mehr?
Doch.
Aber ich benutze das immer. Und deswegen will ich das in meinem fucking Master Slide haben und da war es auch immer. Und irgendwie im neuen Kino sind sie der Meinung, nö, das kann man jetzt im Master Slide nicht mehr einstellen. Weil es zu kompliziert, braucht zu viel CPU-Power und den heutigen 3D-Steinen lässt sich das wirklich nicht mehr realisieren. Was weiß ich, was sich da treibt? Es macht mich wahnsinnig. Ich nehme es weg ohne Grund. Also ohne, ohne dass sie einen nennen.
Was ist der Master Slide?
Der Master Slide ist quasi dein Template, wie dein Slide aussieht.
Bei der Präsentation geht alles, aber wenn du das so einzeln durchklickst, dann ist es nur...
Ich muss jetzt auf jeden einzelnen Slide draufgehen und jeden einzelnen Textblock so von Hand animieren.
Anstatt das per Default im Template.
Anstatt einmal zu sagen, alle Seiten von diesem Typ da funktioniert das so.
Völlig gaga.
Klar, ich könnte jetzt ein anderes... Wahrscheinlich weiß ich, was ich da für ein Argument haben soll. Das ist outdated, Steve ist tot und so weiter. Das benutzt jetzt keiner mehr. Ich weiß nicht, was die Argumentation ist. Sie erklären es einem ja auch nicht. Das ist auch das, was mich so wahnsinnig macht. Stattdessen immer iCloud, iCloud, iCloud und Siri und iCloud.
Wann habt ihr das letzte Mal Siri benutzt?
Soll ich ehrlich sein?
Ich hab es noch nie benutzt.
Nicht mal zum Timer stellen.
Hat ja gar keinen iOS 7, ach so, bei 6 gab's auch schon.
Das mach ich tatsächlich einmal im Jahr.
Wann hab ich dich das letzte Mal benutzt?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das richtig verstanden habe.
So ist das nämlich immer, wenn ich sowas teste, dann geht's immer nicht.
So sieht's aus und dann hat man nämlich keinen Bock mehr. Ja, Siri, ich will Cortana.
Wann hab ich dich das letzte Mal benutzt? Das ist mein Siri Schlauer. Ich schau mal nach.
Zweimal benutzt.
Aufschreiben Sendungstitel.
Außerdem gibt es so eine Medion-Overlock-Nähmaschine.
Teichschlammsauger 2000.
SR2000, ja.
Was kommt bei dir als drittes?
Kondom zweimal benutzt.
erdbeerlounge.de.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie oft man sie benutzt hat.
Also ich bin einfach grundsätzlich angepisst gewesen von Spracherkennung, weil sie sich immer von alleine aktiviert. Das lässt sich ja auch nicht komplett abscheiden. Also du kannst zwar Siri abscheiden, aber dann kommt diese alte Spracherkennung, die kannst du nicht abscheiden. Warum kann ich diesem blöden Telefon nicht sagen, ich will nicht mit dir sprechen? Nein. Ja, aber dann kommt diese alte Spracherkennung, wie sie früher war.
Ach so, wenn man so ganz lange drückt irgendwie, wa?
Ja, das heißt, du setzt dich halt auf dein Telefon, weil das hinten in der Hosentasche ist, und du machst BIP BIP. Ich will aber nicht, dass mein Telefon BIP BIP sagt und dann vielleicht noch irgendwas versteht und daraufhin irgendwas tut.
Vor allem irgendwie.
Es ist echt, ja, da schaut man das Ding nicht mit dem Arsch an und dann reagierst du trotzdem noch.
Ja, mein größter Hässel ist ja immer noch nach wie vor, dass mein Telefon auf Englisch ist und ich dem Siri in Maps nicht angewöhnen kann, die Straßen in Deutsch auszusprechen und dann kriege ich Kaiser Wilhelm Straß oder Schodewicki Straß oder was auch immer. Das ist auch, naja. Aber Apple Maps finde ich tatsächlich immer besser, ne?
Wusstet ihr übrigens, dass auf Mac... Und?
Und?
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass auf Mac, wenn ein Programm Maps benutzen will, dass sie im App Store sein müssen?
Musst du auch im App Store sein.
Ja, und dann kann mir mal irgendjemand mal erklären...
Warum?
Na, weil das ist doch wie bei Google. Du kannst nicht einfach so auf deren Apis zugreifen. Du brauchst irgendwie so ein Key, weil die nicht wollen, dass irgendwelche mit ihren El Chipo-Apps, zum Beispiel auch auf Linux, dann irgendwie die Apple Maps benutzen. Sonst könnte ja jeder kommen und da zugreifen. Das wollen die nicht. Das geht ja bei Google auch nicht. Wenn du bei Google kannst du erstmal loslegen und kaum hast du über 50.000 Connections und so, dann musst du da mit Google Account und Anmelden machen. Das heißt, immer wenn es in Richtung Commercial geht, dann wollen die schon abgreifen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wollen sie verhindern, dass jemand das halt einfach crawlt.
Genau, das auch, ja.
Und einfach mal sämtliche Daten, Kartendaten rauscrawlt oder so.
Tim ist fast geneigt, das gelten zu lassen.
Das ist zumindest jetzt mal eine Argumentation, die ich nachvollziehen kann.
Ne, aber sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel eine Straße, die ich angeprangert habe, dass sie die nicht kennen und mich da theoretisch ins Nirwana führen wollten oder denken, dass ich ins Nirwana führe. Die haben sie jetzt aktualisiert. Also da kommt auch die ganze Zeit neue Content. Und das ist tatsächlich mittlerweile zumindest in Berlin, sind auch so von den Points of Interest schon erstaunlich viele Sachen da, wo ich vor einer Weile noch gewettet hätte, dass Apple Maps sie nicht hat.
Warte mal, jetzt guck ich immer erstmal, ich guck immer erstmal, erstmal im Tempelhofer Feld, ob es noch ein Flughafen ist. Nein, ist kein Flughafen mehr. Das haben sie immerhin mal hinten gekriegt. Und dann...
Man kriegt jetzt auch eine Nachricht, wenn man da Verbesserungen abgibt, dann kriegt man ein paar iMessages, auch gestätigt, dass sie es geändert haben.
Aber was sie noch nicht haben, Hermannplatz ist nach wie vor kein U-Bahnhof, obwohl sich da zwei U-Bahnlinien kreuzen.
UPNV haben sie halt nicht so richtig drin.
Ja, amerikanische Unternehmen und UPNV.
Also so die halbe U7 ist irgendwie nicht drin.
Also das ist, das ist... Oder erklär mir überhaupt mal, ich meine, das ist bei Google ja auch nicht besser.
Google Maps wird auch immer schlechter jetzt tatsächlich, finde ich, von dem Interface und so.
Ja, Interface ist von Google. Man kann das alte Google Maps noch mal einschalten übrigens. Falls irgendjemand gestresst ist von dem neuen Interface.
Sehr gerne, ja bitte.
Du musst auf dieses Dingsbums klicken.
Auf das Schnuffi?
Den Pac-Man?
Nee, nicht den Pac-Man, sondern wenn du das neue Interface hast...
Geh weg.
Dann unten hast du so ein Settings-Rädchen und daneben hast du noch ein Fragezeichen. Wenn du aufs Fragezeichen gehst, dann gibt es da die Optionen. Da kommt ein Fenster, da kannst du sagen Return to Classic Google Maps. Dann fragen sie sich auch noch warum.
Und dann kannst du auch noch sagen...
Einfach alles anklicken, select all.
Interessant ist, jetzt steht hier Missing Features, prefer old Google Maps. Map is covered by boxes. Ah ja, genau, das meinte ich hier. Das klick ich dann immer. Ist es auch langsam, weiß ich nicht. Mein Hauptproblem ist, dass dieser komische Lappen sich da die ganze Zeit über meine Karte ergießt. Und ich finde einfach mal so eine Trennung.
Also was mich bei Google Maps irgendwie immer noch Tiere stört, ist, dass man damit irgendwie nicht zoomen und nicht scrollen und nichts kann. Also er zoomt, wenn man scrollt. Also das geht einfach nicht.
Wie er zoomt, wenn man scrollt.
Oder macht er das jetzt nicht?
Ich mache mal Doppelklick wie auf dem Phone oder auf den Apple Maps und für den ist es aber gleich dann bis auf total ran zoomen. Dabei will ich nur eine Stufe weiter so.
Also die Pinch-Geste wäre ja zoomen.
Ne, die ist ja von Safari schon belegt.
Und wenn ich jetzt aber die Map verschieben will, dann würde ich das ja eigentlich mit der Scroll-Geste machen. Die Scroll-Geste, aber zoomt die Karte.
Ja, weil die Leute ja ihr Mausrad benutzen wollen.
Ja, welches Mausrad will man?
Na ja, das Mausrad.
Ich hab seit Jahren kein Mausrad mehr.
Na ja, aber das ist einfach so, die benutzen da alle, weiß nicht, was die da benutzen, aber...
Also ich find das unbenutzbar.
Das ist in der Tat ein echtes Drama. Wobei naja, gut Webseiten und Integration.
Aber ich hab generell auch so, also ich weiß nicht so, dass mit dieser Software, das wird generell, hab ich so den Eindruck, vor allen Dingen, die mit User Interface immer schlimmer. Also ich erwisch mich immer öfter so, ich probier ein Programm aus und man denkt sich so, okay, ihr macht ein Programm für diesen Use-Case. Wenn man fünf Minuten drüber nachdenkt, fallen einem die Features ein, die man auf jeden Fall gerne hätte. Und meistens fehlt die Hälfte einfach. Und man fragt sich immer, was machen die da? Benutzt die das nicht selber? Fällt ihnen das nicht auf?
Ja, das kommt mir auch häufiger vor. Und wie gesagt, manchmal mit so komplett obvious Sachen. Es wird schlimmer.
Es wird schlimmer, ja. Ich weiß nicht, was dazu geführt hat, ob es die schleichende Cloudifizierung ist oder die...
Oder alle machen nur noch mobile.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ich glaube einfach, die meisten Leute scheißen einfach drauf. Und denen ist das irgendwie alles nicht so wichtig. Und sie reden zwar in die eine Richtung, aber sie handeln in die andere Richtung.
Aber die benutzen das doch auch selber immer.
Und das verstehe ich nicht.
Da sind wir ja bei meinem Thema der Woche.
Was ist denn dein Rant der Woche?
Na, es ist jetzt nicht ein Rant, sondern es ist mehr ein... Ja, ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wie ich mich da jetzt fühlen soll, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber ihr werdet ja sicherlich mitbekommen, dass up.net das Team so einen Blogpost rausgelassen hat, in dem sie im Wesentlichen erklärt haben, dass jüngst relativ viele der User dran waren mit einer Renewal. Also dass der Jahreskauf, den sie vor einem Jahr gemacht haben, quasi jetzt wieder anstand, um ihren bezahlten Account zu verlängern. Und dass wohl die Zahl der Leute, die das tagtäglich getan haben, nicht so hoch war, wie sie sich das erwünscht hätten. Und sie haben zwar jetzt keine Zahlen genannt, auch keine Prozentzahlen, aber sie meinten, es wäre halt so, dass die Kohle, die jetzt eben über bezahlte Accounts aus diesem System herausgeneriert werden könnte, nicht mehr reicht, um die Leute zu bezahlen, die da halt in dieser Company arbeiten. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie viel das waren, aber das wären sicherlich so 6, 7, 8, 9 Leute gewesen sein. Und deswegen entlassen sie all diese Leute und es bleiben einfach nur noch die Founder über, also dieser Brian Burke und vor allem der Dalton Caldwell, die so auf Contract-Basis, wie das so schön heißt, aus diesem Geld, was hier jetzt trotzdem noch reinkommt, immer mal wieder Dinge beitragen, im Wesentlichen den Überblick wahrscheinlich auch behalten, also das System-Monitoring vornehmen und die Kohle zahlt halt die Server und alles bleibt erst mal so wie es ist. So, daraus kann man, und das wurde ja auch vielerorts getan, den Schluss ziehen, dass es sozusagen das Ende vom Lead ist und dass Abdotnet ein großer Fail ist und seine Ziele nicht erreicht hat. Seine Ziele hat es sicherlich nicht erreicht. Kann man schon mal festhalten. Ja, nur es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es abgeschaltet wird. Es läuft halt weiter. Vorerst. Wie lange vorerst ist, ist unklar. In der Blogpost ist die Rede von indefinitely. Also es heißt zumindest nicht, dass es jetzt noch zwei Jahre laufen soll und dann ist vorbei oder ein Jahr, sondern halt solange es sich tragen kann. So interpretiere ich das jetzt mal. Außerdem, also aus dieser Kohle werden halt nicht nur die Server bezahlt, sondern es werden auch Leute bezahlt, die halt Support machen. Klar, weil es wird immer wieder Issues geben und Fragen geben und keine Ahnung, Security-Problematiken etc. werden aufkommen. Und sie wollen halt Sachen im Source Code veröffentlichen und haben das jetzt auch schon getan für viele der Hauptanwendungen. Also das Alpha, also Omega hatten sie ja schon, dieses Private Messaging, das ist ja nur so ein JavaScript-Kram, dann haben sie irgendwie Alpha, was in Python geschrieben ist, also die eigentliche Twitter-Webseitenartige Präsenz, mit der man halt die ganzen Settings machen kann, bzw. das ganze Microblogging machen kann. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, wollen sie wohl auch tatsächlich Schritt für Schritt den Chore lesen. Also es geht nicht nur um die Anwendung, sondern da sind sie für meinen Geschmack noch sehr unklar, aber sie wollen, wenn man so die Tweets quer liest, Schritt für Schritt in definierten Paketeinheiten dieses System quasi open sourcen. Tja, was machen wir da jetzt draus? Ich finde das sehr bedrückend, weil es einfach bedeutet, dass eigentlich jetzt mal wieder keine gute Option am Start ist, wo es hier, also angenommen, das würde jetzt mittelfristig das Ende des Projektes bedeuten, was für mich nicht hundertprozentig ausgemachte Sache ist. Da ist die Frage, was denn sonst? So, der Mike guckt jetzt Twitter an. Na ich mein, der Laden macht irgendwie 350 Millionen Dollar Miese pro Quartal. Da geht's irgendwie ADN echt besser. Ja, gut, Twitter bezahlt wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Menge Leute und wenn man irgendwie deren Personal entlassen würde, dann würden sie vielleicht auch einen Plus machen, von daher sind sie vielleicht irgendwie etwa auf dem selben Level, keine Ahnung. Aber wir haben natürlich auf jeden Fall den Vorteil des Network-Effekts, sie sind halt sowieso schon überall und würden halt nicht so ohne weiteres fallen gelassen werden. Was nicht heißt, dass es jetzt hier keine Community gibt, die das nicht auch gerne verteidigt sehen möchte. Weil, ich meine, mal ehrlich, Twitter, wo Leute Leerzeichen in URLs reinbauen, wenn sie sie dir per Privatnachricht schicken, damit die ankommt, geht's noch? Was kommt als nächstes? Also, das ist ja so, als würde ich irgendwie, damit eine Nachricht übertragen werden, kann sie vorher noch nach Appstick-Code übersetzen müssen oder sowas.
Ein Schritt vor, zwei zurück.
Oder heute keine Umlaute, irgendwie so. Dienstags keine Umlaute.
Das wäre mal eine Maßnahme bei Eltsin-Appstick.
Das ist doch einfach kein System, mit dem man kommunizieren kann.
Oder wie?
Und Twitter legt halt täglich Sachen oben drauf. Und vor allem Twitter entwickelt sich halt so, jetzt haben sie dieses neue tolle Feature, jetzt bis zu fünf Bildern pro Tweet. Kannst du Bilder machen und dann kannst du da auch noch reinschreiben, wer es ist. Also du kannst auch im Bild sagen, das war jetzt...
Du meinst, ihre Face-Erkennung ist nicht so toll, man soll ihnen jetzt ein bisschen helfen.
Ja, die User liefern halt sozusagen das Fleisch, mit dem man dann halt irgendwie vermarkten kann. Und natürlich macht es dieses Feature aber nicht ins AP. Was heißt, Third Party darf das dann auch nicht benutzen. Also man kann grundsätzlich davon ausgehen, alle neuen Features in Twitter, wird Twitter selbst vorbehalten bleiben. Das wird nur mit der Webseite und mit den offiziellen Clients machbar sein. Und auch solche Sachen wie Tweetbot sind dann weg. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn Tweetbot nicht mehr zu benutzen ist, ich meine, die haben ja auch irgendwann ihr User-Limit erreicht, dann kann ich auch mit Twitter auf einmal nichts mehr, also dann kann ich das nicht benutzen. Also dann wäre dieses Echo-Phone schon gestorben, dann wäre es für mich wahrscheinlich schon nicht mehr benutzbar gewesen. Und auf dem iPhone ist es ähnlich. Und auf anderen Plattformen weiß ich jetzt überhaupt nicht, wie soll sich jetzt eine neue Plattform überhaupt etablieren, wenn es da keine Set-Party-Anwendungen gibt, die da einfach mithalten. Vielleicht geht es euch da anders, aber für mich ist es einfach diese, ich kann zwischen verschiedenen User-Interfaces wählen, um so einen Dienst effizient zu benutzen. Und es gibt auch so einen gesunden Battle zwischen diesen Anwendungen. Also alles, was Twitter heute ausmacht, ist nicht bei Twitter erfunden worden. Das fängt bei dem Ad an. Da sind sie schon nicht drauf gekommen, das haben sich die User irgendwie selber ausgedacht. Der Name, also Tweet, ist auch von dem Twitterific. Überhaupt diese ganze Vogelkonnotation gab es am Anfang so gar nicht.
Woher kam denn der Originalname? Das war doch T-W-T-T-R einfach nur?
Da fehlt ja noch das E-R. So fing es dann irgendwie an. Dann Twitter und dann kam dann irgendwann Twitterific raus, die diesen Twitter-Sound da überhaupt erst mal eingebaut haben. Und viele Dinge sind überhaupt erst mit Third-Party-Klans entwickelt worden beziehungsweise sind einfach durch die Community erfunden worden. Und eigentlich hat Twitter selber fast überhaupt nichts erfunden. Aber es ist ja egal.
Was haben uns die Römer schon?
Was hat Twitter jemals für uns getan? Also ich finde Twitter einfach in zunehmendem Maße uninteressant beziehungsweise einfach unbenutzbar und von daher für mich persönlich als eine Zumutung, wo es sich mir auch einfach in den Weg stellt. Und als sie dann irgendwie angefangen haben, URLs nicht mehr in Privatnachrichten zu erlauben beziehungsweise auch überhaupt forcibly alle URLs werden redirected. Das finde ich irgendwie schon... Ja, ich meine, ihr kennt diesen Fall. Angenommen, ich unterhalte mich jetzt über Twitter mit jemanden über irgendeinen Softwarefeature.
Kommt schon mal vor.
Und man sagt dann so, man unterhält sich darüber, wie eine URL aussehen könnte. Schreibt also quasi ausgedachte example.com Sachen hin und so weiter. Experimentiert damit rum, aber du kriegst halt immer nur irgendwie t.co.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer durch diese neuen Top-Level-Domänen. Das ist jetzt inzwischen fast alles, was irgendwie einen Punkt drin hat, für die eine Domäne.
Ja, genau.
Aber die sind doch nur so doof, das zu verschleiern. Sie könnten ja eigentlich auch die richtige URL anzeigen. Wenn du klickst, geht da dann trotzdem nach tc, tralala. Also ich meine, wenn du bei Google klickst, dann landest du auch erstmal bei Google und wirst es eigentlich nicht weiter.
Die sollen mich einfach in Frieden lassen und die sollen meinen Content nicht anfassen. Das ist halt einfach das, was mich so wahnsinnig macht. Das macht mich auch bei Facebook wahnsinnig. Das macht mich bei allem wahnsinnig. Alles, was mir irgendwie in meinen Content reingeht und was filtert und umschreibt und der Meinung ist, es müsste irgendwas interpretieren, was ich einfach nicht interpretiert haben möchte, das ist einfach Scheiße. So. Und deswegen liebe ich up.net, weil es geht mir einfach nicht in meinen Scheiß rein.
Scheißt ja nicht in deinen Scheiß rein.
Scheißt mir nicht in den Scheiß. Und da bleiben die URLs, wie sie sind und da sind einfach Nachrichten, so wie sie sind und vor allem gehört einfach mir und nicht irgendjemand, der dann der Meinung ist, er müsste das irgendwie monetarisieren. Auf irgendeinem Umweg durch das Einblenden oder Ausblenden oder keine Ahnung, dass du auf einmal in irgendeiner Werbung verwendet wirst etc. Und ich finde es auch so absurd und auch so... Was mich wirklich so ein bisschen... Wie sagt man dazu? So ein bisschen... Ich suche gerade nach dem richtigen Wort.
Die Spucke wegbleiben lässt.
Ah, weiß nicht so.
Also was mich so ein bisschen anschürft, ist kein gutes Wort. An-schürf. Wie nennt man denn das, wenn man so eine Schürfverletzung hat? Irgendwie so ein Kratz, keine Ahnung, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall. Alle wollen immer, ja, meine Daten gehören mir, privacy, selbstbestimmte Präsenz im Internet, etc. Man muss irgendwie die Kommunikationsmittel beherrschen, etc. Und dann kommt irgendwie mal so ein Dienst daher. Dann also, äh, drei Dollar im Monat. Das ist irgendwie so alles, was irgendwie zählt. Wo kommen wir denn da hin und so weiter? Und dann gehen sie halt wieder irgendwie auf Twitter und nehmen ihr Röhrchen in den Mund und... Geht doch!
In die Nase nimmt man das Röhrchen, nicht in den Mund.
Ich krieg da alles, was ich brauche.
Funktioniert sogar bei Edge.
Das kotzt mich an.
Jetzt übertreibst du aber.
Nein!
Leute, beschränken sich einfach. Ich will mich nicht beschränken. Ich will Zukunft. Und nicht so'n Dreck.
Jetzt.
Morgen vor allen Dingen.
Zeitnah, wenigstens.
Wo sind wir denn, weil man wieder bezahlen muss? Ich hab noch keine Update-Net-Mail bekommen, glaube ich.
Hängt davon ab, wenn du letztes Mal bezahlt hast.
Wie bei Mordbox, wir werden dir nichts mehr hinschieben, Sicherheit halber.
Na ja, also erstmal finde ich die Ansage gut, dass sie weiterlaufen. Der Dienst ist ja nicht weg. Es ist nur das Problem, dass jetzt sozusagen so eine allgemeine Erwartungshaltung da ist. Ah, jetzt haben sie solche Einschnitte gemacht. Jetzt ist es natürlich zwangsläufig vorbei. Das kann natürlich passieren. Noch ist es allerdings da. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin froh, dass es noch da ist, weil wenn es jetzt weg wäre, würde ich mich sofort sorgen, wie ich denn jetzt bitte meine Kommunikation verbessern kann. Weil irgendwie mit Twitter und so weiter geht es einfach nicht. Und jetzt kommt natürlich auch die Frage, was passiert jetzt? Mittlerweile ist auf ADN eine wilde Diskussion entbrannt, mit wie es denn jetzt weitergeht. Unter the.abstract.net also the.appstractstract.net Das redirectet dann hier auf so eine GitHub-Seite, die wiederum Ressourcen zeigt, wo es jetzt sozusagen um die Zukunft geht und alle bereiten sich quasi für verschiedene Szenarien vor. Bis hin zu dem Szenario mit, was ist, sollte der Dienst als solcher gar nicht mehr laufen. Es gibt allerlei Ideen. Ich hab da noch keinen richtigen Überblick. Es gibt ein dickes, fettes Trello-Board. Es gibt drei Trello-Boards. Eines heißt General Discussion. Da ist eine ganze Menge drauf los. Wo irgendwie über jeden Scheiß geredet wird. Also über Feature, Wishlist, was man eigentlich ja noch alles haben wollte. Use Cases, Funding, Third-Party-Ideen, Marketing, blablabla, Ressourcen nochmal, wo irgendwie über alles gesprochen wird. Dann wird Trello eingestellt. Dann ist aber wirklich vorbei mit dem Internet, wenn Trello auch noch eingestellt wird.
Oh, ich seh grad, ich bin auf dem Free-Plan. Ich wohl meine E-Mail nicht gesehen, was ich mal wieder bezahlen soll.
So, dann...
Ich bin ein Teil des Problems.
Ja, genau. Du hast deine E-Mail nicht gelesen. Es gibt Projekte, die die API-Proxien, also so Apps, die selber die API implementieren, um irgendwie so als Zwischenschalter zu funktionieren etc. Also API-Replizierung etc.
Aber es ist halt die Frage, was passiert.
Sie haben jetzt auch noch ins Gespräch gebracht, dass sie sich vorstellen können, also zum Beispiel dieses Backer-System, das ich neulich vorgestellt habe, also ihre eigene Crowdfunding-Plattform. Der Dalton meinte jetzt, dass sie das gebaut haben. Einer der Gründe war, quasi, dass sie eben, sollte diese Phase eben so ausgehen, wie sie ausgegangen ist, dann ein Tool haben, mit dem sie quasi neue Features darüber finanzieren können. Also kann sehr gut sein, dass sie sagen, wir sehen, dass das und das sollte hier noch geschehen. Es gibt noch genug Interesse in die Plattform. Wir können das aber nur machen, wenn das und das Crowdfunding zusammenkommen. Ob das so sustainable ist, weiß ich nicht. Ist aber auf jeden Fall noch mal eine interessante Option. Gegeben den Hintergrund, dass ja auch ab dort nicht überhaupt erst durch so ein Crowdfunding gestartet wurde. Das kann man natürlich jetzt auch nicht alle drei Monate wieder neu durchziehen, weil ich glaube nicht, dass das genug fängt. Aber who knows. Und dann gibt es noch eine ganz interessante Debatte darüber, was denn jetzt wäre, wenn das jetzt jemand kauft. vielleicht wäre das ja ein System, was für andere Firmen auch interessant ist.
Sollen wir die dann den gleichen Scheiß machen wie Twitter und Facebook?
Ja, oder auch nicht. Also es gibt einen Podcast, ADN-Views, den habe ich mir irgendwie angehört. Da hat er mal so ein bisschen frei gedreht. Und ist mal so alle Optionen durchgegangen. Wer denn so theoretisch, also ohne dass das jetzt zu viel Realitätsbezug haben muss, aber nur so was wäre wenn? Was wäre wenn Apple ADN kauft? Was wäre wenn Microsoft ADN kauft? Und das will ich gar nicht wiederholen, aber was ein Gedanke, den ich sehr interessant fand, ist, was wäre wenn Dropbox ADN kauft?
Die werden selber demnächst gekauft.
Von?
Keine Ahnung, weil sie im Weg stehen. Viele User haben viele Daten und irgendeine Datenkacke greift da denen nicht zu. Facebook oder Google.
Da müssen sie sich natürlich auch kaufen lassen wollen. Die sollten ja schon mal gekauft werden.
Das ist nicht so das Problem. Mit dem sich nicht kaufen lassen wollen. Da ist irgendein Venture Capital Bude drin, die hat halt einfach ihren Wecker gestellt. Wenn der abgelaufen ist, kommt der nächste Buyer vorbei, wird das Cash mitgenommen und fertig.
Kann sein.
Oder die machen genug, dass sie die Investoren schon auszahlen können.
Sagen wir mal, Dropbox denkt jetzt darüber nach, im Sinne von was ist für uns gut? Bisher haben sie sich halt nur in dem Bereich bewegt, Storage zu verkaufen. Damit fing es irgendwie an. Das war ja im Prinzip ein Hit. Dropbox ist super populär und viele Leute hatten da genau dieses Problem. Diese Internetfestplatte muss man sagen, das hat Dropbox als erstes richtig hinbekommen und es funktioniert vor allem auch gut.
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es Google Drive, jetzt gibt es Microsoft Drive, jetzt gibt es irgendwie...
Ja, aber es ist second to the game und funktioniert halt nicht so gut und ist schon gar nicht so verbreitet wie Dropbox. Für Dropbox geht es jetzt vor allem darum, neue Sachen anzubieten, die den Leuten, die sie schon haben, auch eine Perspektive bieten dazu bleiben und nicht irgendwie auf Google Drive zu wechseln.
Ja, aber ich sagte ja, bei Dropbox ist es einfach auch auf Schweine teuer. Ja, die Frage ist, wie viel von diesen Usern haben sie in ihrem 2 GB Free-Account-Level? Und wie viel zahlen die User haben sie?
Keine Ahnung.
Weil ich kenne sehr, sehr viele Leute, die Dropbox nutzen, aber nur die allerwenigsten davon tun auch wirklich ein Geld drüber. Die versuchen mit diesen 2 GB klarzukommen oder was das ist und den Rest schummen sich drum rum oder setzen parallel BitTorrent, Sync oder sonst was auf, damit sie ja dem Dropbox kein Dollar rüberschieben müssen. Also jetzt noch zu die Frage, wie profitable die sind.
Profitable sind sie, aber der Punkt ist, sie müssen ihr Produkt verbessern. Sie müssen etwas bieten, was sie derzeit nicht haben, damit sie diese kritische Masse an Leuten überzeugen, da einzusteigen. Würden sie jetzt zum Beispiel ADN kaufen? Ob die sich kaufen lassen? Andere Frage, ob sie es wirklich wollen. Keine Ahnung, ob sie zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gekauft sind. Auch andere Frage. Nur mal das durchgedacht. Was würden sie damit bekommen? Sie würden quasi zusätzlich zu ihrem Wir bieten euch Storage an, was ja übrigens auch Dropbox gemacht hat und auch up.net gemacht hat. Nur mit einem leicht anderen Modell, aber das ließ sie sich sicherlich verheiraten. Man könnte sagen, ok, jetzt gibt es hier auch noch ein API, was so ähnlich ist wie up.net API, was auch noch die Dropbox-Files mit abbildet. Das ist ja nun kein großes Problem, zumal sie da auch schon die Erfahrung haben, wie das funktionieren kann. Dann könnte man das sicherlich miteinander verheiraten auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. Aber du würdest eben auch diese ganze Messaging-Geschichte noch mit dazu bekommen, was Dropbox derzeit einfach überhaupt nicht hat. Du kannst nicht über Dropbox kommunizieren. Aber wie gerne würde man vielleicht manchmal über Dropbox kommunizieren, wenn man schon die Files dahin legt. Du benutzt immer noch einen Side-Channel, zu sagen, habe ich dir in die Dropbox gelegt. Du kannst aber nicht durch die Dropbox selber eine Push-Notification, jemanden auf den Screen werfen, in irgendeiner App, wo man rumchatten kann. Das würde schon sehr gut passen. Naja, wir wissen nicht, ob es funktioniert. Aber das wäre auf jeden Fall auch etwas, was passieren könnte. Ob ich da jetzt besonders glücklich mit wäre, weiß ich nicht. Ja, nicht, weil am Ende, wie du schon so schön sagst, kommt dann wieder der nächste große Fisch und kauft das.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, warum ich bei Dropbox irgendwie immer noch kein Geld einwerfe, ist, dass der Unterschied zwischen free und erster Bezahl-Account, der ist einfach so riesig. Also man bezahlt relativ viel für das kleinste Bezahl-Tier und bekommt auch unglaublich viel Speicher, den ich gar nicht brauche. Das ist mein Problem an der Sache.
Ja, aber andere Leute, andere Use-Cases. Also für mich zum Beispiel war das keine große Frage.
Ja, das ist hier pro. Ok, 1,99 pro Monat ist jetzt nicht so viel, aber 100 Gigabyte ist mir, das brauch ich halt nicht. 9,99. Ja, 10 pro Monat.
Ja, 10 pro Monat ist doch schon nicht wenig. Was kostet ein Github im kleinsten pro Monat?
Und Dropbox de-publiciert nicht nach sieben Tagen.
Was?
Das weiß ich nicht, was das Github so kostet von sich aus.
Also die 9,99 stören mich jetzt weniger, als diese 100 Gigabyte, die ich einfach nicht brauche.
Also ich nutze derzeit 88 von meinen 145.
Hier kann viel durchgeweicht werden in die On-Cloud, aber gut, das muss man nachrechnen, was die Daten.
Was mich noch so ein bisschen stört, ist, dass es für Dropbox halt irgendwie auch kein Freebies-Decline gibt oder so. Ja. Das macht wiederum, bevor und süngt, ganz gut.
Oder Amazon, da gibt es ja immerhin dieses S3-Command, was es überall gibt.
Leider hat sich Dropbox ja auch so ein bisschen etabliert. Ich sage jetzt mal leider. Das war sehr viele Applikationen auf dem iPhone, die irgendwie miteinander oder untereinander kommunizieren wollen, die das entweder nicht über iCloud tun wollen oder wo sie wissen, dass ihre User das nicht wollen, benutzen dann diese Dropbox-ARPI. Ich habe da etliche von, die das machen.
Ich habe mir die auch mal angeguckt. Die ist auch dead simple to use. Und sie funktioniert halt auch. iCloud ist zwar vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher noch zu benutzen, aber nur, wenn es gerade mal funktioniert.
Die machen sich davon halt eben auch so abhängig. Das verwebt sich alles so ein bisschen.
Ja, aber mit iCloud bist du ja nicht weniger abhängig.
Man könnte WebDAF zum Beispiel benutzen oder andere Standards, dass man wieder seinen eigenen Server machen kann. Zum Beispiel bei One Password, was dich auch benutzen stört, mich das echt so ein bisschen. Ich habe ja meine eigene Server, die auch Standard sprechen wie WebDAF. Der kann mehr, aber er kann zum Beispiel keinen WebDAF. Der kann wieder iCloud und, was weiß ich, gucken wir nach. Das ist noch so ein Punkt. Die etablieren sich gerade mit ihrem proprietären Zeugs als Standard. Und das sehe ich mit einem Lachen und einem Bein in den Auge.
Naja, als Entwickler, ich kenne das halt. In der alten Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe, da hatten wir halt sowas wie eigenen Web-DAF-Server unterstützen und so weiter. Und das ist halt ein Pain in the Ass. Weil die Leute, die kriegen das halt zu einem einfach zu großen, kleinen Anteil nicht gebacken, ihren Web-DAF-Server ordentlich aufzusetzen. Und dann ist der nicht ordentlich connectable. Und dieses und jenes. Und dann hast du halt wieder deine Queue voll mit Support-Tickets, die du gar nicht sehen willst. Weißt du, ich meine, du hast ja gerade eben lange darüber geredet, was du alles gemacht hast, damit die Leute eben nicht ankommen.
Ja, ich versteh das schon.
Und Web-DAF nicht zu unterstützen, ist in dem Sinne eine Maßnahme. Weil Web-DAF halt nicht reliably funktioniert. Für alle User da draußen.
Das ist einfach so. Ja, ist verständlich, aber trotzdem ärgerlich. One Password macht zumindest nur Dropbox und iCloud. Und ansonsten kann man jetzt auch Sync-Using-Wi-Fi machen oder Import vom iTunes.
Naja, also... up.net, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was passieren wird. Es ist ein bisschen wenig Kommunikation für meinen Geschmack. Andererseits muss man dem Team zumindest zugestehen, dass sie sich frühzeitig über Lösungswege Gedanken machen und dass das Ganze jetzt nicht schon gegen irgendeine Wand gefahren ist, wo es Puff macht und dann ist auf einmal alles weg. Du hörst irgendwie nur noch so ein...
Du redest jetzt vom Mt. Gox-Szenario.
Genau, das Mt. Gox-Szenario, das hat hier definitiv nicht stattgefunden. Das ist nach wie vor ein sehr seidig laufender Dienst. Das muss man auch mal anerkennen. Es ist wirklich auch sehr stabil. So Probleme mit ADN, was jetzt so Stabilität, Verfügbarkeit...
Die haben vielleicht doch einfach nicht die User-Anzahl.
Vielleicht nicht?
Nein, vielleicht haben sie nicht, aber trotzdem haben sie diese Probleme nicht. Ich meine, sie könnten ja auch die User-Anzahl nicht haben und trotzdem Probleme haben.
Also Twitter hat ja auch Failwale, gerade als sie am Anfang waren und so viele User hatten wie ADN jetzt, hatten sie halt ständig der Failwale am Fliegen. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ist ja jetzt auch nicht so überraschend. Der Dalton Coltwell hat ja vorher irgendwie Webseiten gefahren mit Millionen von Usern. Also der kannte das Szenario bereits. Das sind jetzt keine Neulinge in dem Business gewesen, sondern der hat vorher schon massiv größer skalierende Sites betrieben. Und das teilt sich an der Stelle. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es zuverlässig, es funktioniert und was man auch echt mal nicht aus dem Blick kriegen sollte, die entstandene Infrastruktur um ADN herum, die Apps, die es gibt, das sind immer noch die besten Apps. Dieses Repost und so weiter. All das, was da ist, schlägt.
Auf dem Desktop sind keine entstanden. Rye ist ganz gut. Was jetzt unbedingt als Desktop bezeichnet.
Ja, es gibt sogar ein Command Line Interface, es gibt Sale, es gibt viele gute Sachen, die es für andere Plattformen überhaupt nicht gibt.
Alter, du Vaderst schon wieder.
Ich bin ich nicht, hier werdet wer anders heute.
Ich hab's heute extra getestet.
Vorhin warst du das nämlich einmal.
Das glaubt ja keiner.
Doch, der hat's weggemacht und ist dann aufgehört.
Keiner weiß wovon ihr redet gerade.
Nichts ist so wie es scheint. Nichts ist so wie es Vadert.
Wie auch immer, man kann sich jetzt über unterschiedliche Plattformen unterscheiden, aber ich würde sagen, wenn du immer verfügbare Clients auf derselben Plattform miteinander vergleichst, im Vergleich zu anderen Systemen, ist einfach die ADN-Infrastruktur fast überall deutlich besser. Also es hat sowohl Varietät, also es gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche Anwendungen, die es mit ganz anderen User-Interface-Ansätzen probieren. Also dieses Felix zum Beispiel ist nicht ganz so mein Geschmack, aber das benutzen viele Leute und da sind auch ein paar coole Ideen drin. Es sind viele Sachen drin umgesetzt worden. Und Repost, wo ich jetzt so eher der Fan von bin, ist einfach geil. Also ich genieße das jeden Tag mit dieser Software zu arbeiten. Und ich muss aber schon so ein bisschen zusammenzucken, wenn ich irgendwie auf Tweetbot zurückgehen muss. Es war auch ein relativ gutes Tool, aber hat für meinen Geschmack schon nicht mehr ganz so diesen Polish. Wird halt auch nicht mehr viel dran gemacht, weil es hat keine Zukunft. Es ist halt zukunftslose Software, weil das Party heißt halt einfach Tod. Und das kann einfach nicht sein, dass wir jetzt auf so eine T&F-Welt hinauslaufen. In der es einfach nur noch Twitter und Facebook badens gibt. Ja genau, das ist tatsächlich mal ein sehr guter Vergleich. Genau, Twitter und Facebook, das ist das neue T&F, wo du einfach nur noch gezwungen bist, diesen Scheißdreck dazu zu konsumieren. Und dir werden dann auch noch diese blöden Clients dazu einfach reingefüttert, die dich eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit nur verlocken wollen, auf Werbung zu klicken, dir anzuschauen oder Daten zu liefern, um für Werbung ausgeliefert zu werden. Und dann beschweren sich wieder alle über ihre verlorene Privatsphäre und ihre mangelnde Durchsetzungskraft. Wir sind ja alle das Produkt. Aber keiner tut was.
Keiner will sich seinen eigenen Schweinestall anschaffen.
Keiner will irgendwie vorwärts kommen. Und ich akzeptiere das nicht und ich sehe das nicht ein. Ich will, dass das hier weitergeht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es gelingen wird, hier so einen Community-Development-Prozess hinzubekommen. Es sind nicht wenig Developer unterwegs auf ADN. Das nicht. Aber die meisten hatten nicht geplant, ADN selber weiterzuentwickeln. Man kann natürlich auch sagen, Feature-Frees sind ja schon weit gekommen in den zwei Jahren. Das ist ja jetzt schon alles irgendwie tausendmal besser als alles andere. Wir wissen, wie es ist. Morgen kommt wieder eine tolle Idee um die Ecke. Wer das nicht hat und nicht einbaut, der wird die Zukunft nicht erleben. Das kann sehr schnell passieren. Aber so oder so. Man kann irgendwie was drauf aufbauen.
Was natürlich auch noch passieren, auch unwahrscheinlich, aber was ist schon wahrscheinlich? Es kann auch dieser Weiße Ritter daherkommen, auf den, meiner Meinung nach, ADN gesetzt hat. Sie haben darauf gesetzt, dass jemand mit einer coolen App daherkommt, die Sachen macht, die alle wollen und die ADN als Backend benutzt. Dann ist das einfach so. Und weil die App so toll ist, benutzen das alle. So wie du dir heute fast in jeder App einen Account klickst. Also wenn jetzt, keine Ahnung, was ein gutes Beispiel ist, Instagram ist so ein bisschen ausgeblutet, die Idee. Aber so etwas wie Instagram oder wie WhatsApp, was auf irgendeine besondere Art einen Dienst anbietet, der einfach geil ist. Und wo du unter anderem auch User-Accounts brauchst, weil du das fast sowieso brauchst. Implizit, explizit, was auch immer. Und in dem Moment, wo du das ADN Backend benutzt, hast du quasi diese ganze Infrastruktur. Du hast halt das Channeling, du hast irgendwie User-Accounts und bezahlen, dieser ganzen Kram ist halt einfach drin. Das musst du nicht selber programmieren. Was ja irgendwie auch mal ziemlich bekloppt ist, dass man quasi das Rad immer wieder neu erfinden muss. Ich bau jetzt mir mal einen neuen Dienst und erstmal User-Accounting machen. Und Profil, Bilder und Pipapo. Das hast du halt abgenommen. Und in dem Moment könnte sich theoretisch halt dieser ganze Dienst immer noch, so wie Phoenix aus der Asche, nach oben ziehen lassen. Das ist natürlich jetzt wieder die Frage, welcher Developer traut sich jetzt auf ADN als Backend noch zu setzen, wenn das alles so in so einem Zwischenzustand lebt.
Naja.
Also ich sag mal, in einem Jahr ist das Ding immer noch da. Läuft noch.
Okay, Prediction hier für die Show-Notes.
Also das...
Ich sag in einem Jahr ist es verkauft.
Verkauft.
Claim-Chowder? Wollt ihr nicht wetten?
Hier, mach mal dein Mikro wieder da Richtung...
Ist mal zu wenig, mal zu viel. So, jetzt besser?
Viel. Viel besser.
Ja, wollt ihr nicht wetten?
Claim-Chowder. Ach wetten, ja, wetten das. Ich meine, klar können wir wetten. Ich will jetzt gar nicht wetten im Sinne von ich bin mir total sicher und ich setze das jetzt durch. Ich sag nur...
Du hoffst es.
Hoffen tue ich, dass es noch länger läuft, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass das System als solches jetzt noch mindestens ein Jahr läuft. Ich bin aus.
Ich bin da nicht so ganz emotional stark dran gebunden. Also ich guck da halt so alle paar Tage mal rein. Hab mir jetzt noch Push-Notifications wieder angemacht, damit ich die kleinen Direct-Messages nicht verpasse.
Ich benutze das halt am laufenden Meter für Direktnachrichten. Also ich bin halt die ganze Zeit mit Leuten, auch mit Gruppen von Leuten in Kontakt. Das ist halt mein Chat und mein Gruppenchat und mein Public Timeline, alles in einem. Hab ich halt sonst noch.
Aber in meiner Social Bubble, die auch noch Schnittmengen mit anderen Dingen hat, die nicht Nerds sind, da funktioniert das halt nicht so gut.
Ja, mit denen red ich rein. Michael Eilt übrigens. Es ist ja auch so ein bisschen Kampf im Netz. Man muss ja schon auch seine Social Bubble einfach zu sich rüberziehen. Ich meine, für dich so als Vollnerd ist es ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein bisschen so ein Malus, wenn du dich jetzt sozusagen von den Nichtwissern in ihre Nichtwissernetze ziehen lässt. Ich meine, du gehst ja auch nicht in schlechte Bars oder in scheiß Klubs. Du gehst ja nicht irgendwo hin und dann läuft den ganzen Tag nur Helene Fischer und so. So komm ich mir vor bei Twitter. Das ist Musikanten-Stade irgendwie.
Mutanten-Stade.
Ja, das ist auch schon eine ganz schöne Brüllaffenveranstaltung manchmal. Also Twitter.
Ja, ist furchtbar. Und Facebook ist halt das Ganze nochmal so zum Quadrat. Das ist so, wie Musikanten-Stade läuft, während du noch bei deiner Oma sitzt und sie die ganze Zeit den Kuchen andrehen will, weil du noch schon als Kind nicht gemocht hast.
Oh, jetzt kommt die Kindheitstraumata.
Du hast deine Oma nicht im Griff und sie vor deinen Augen den Tele-Gebäckständer aufklappt.
Genau, und irgendwie... Ja, und keine Ahnung. Und dir dann irgendwie nebenbei noch irgendwie erzählt von der Judenverschwörung und irgendwie tausend anderer Sachen, die du noch nie wissen wolltest und schon immer für komplett bekloppt gehalten hast und irgendwie auch... Kindheitstreit.
Meiner Oma kann ich sagen, welchen Kuchen ich habe.
Ja, vielleicht war Oma jetzt nicht das beste Beispiel. Da hat ihr ja wieder ein anderes Bild. Aber ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Es gibt schon so Orte, da begeben wir uns einfach ungern hin. Ich bin da so selten. Sag mal was, wo ihr sehr ungern seid. U-Bahn. U-Bahn.
Oder wie ich es liebevoll nenne, Geisterbahn.
Tante vielleicht.
Na, aber ihr kennt doch sicherlich dieses Problem. Ihr habt da mal, was weiß ich, ihr müsst mal Geld wechseln und dann geht ihr in den nächsten Laden rein und dann macht ihr so und du bist in so einer komplett anderen Realität.
Naja, so Realitätsschauer.
Geldautomatenläden.
Bankenhallen.
Spielhallen, genau.
Spielunken.
Spielunken?
Ich war mal, als irgendwie noch DDR war, war ich mal so zur Leipziger Messe in so einem völlig absurden Restaurant, was ausschließlich so für Westgäste hergerichtet war. Zur Rennbahn hieß das. Das war so geschmacklos. Ein Traum wär mir nicht eingefallen, was so geschmacklos ist. So Barsitze aus so Pferdejochs. Und natürlich war der Kronleuchter so ein Wagenrad. Und alle Stühle hatten so Pferdefüße. Das war beyond. Aber das Geilste war wirklich so der DJ, der hinter seinem so mit so Bettlaken abgespannten Tresen-Dingsbums stand, so irgendwie stocksteif, irgendwie immer so, sich das Mikrofon nahm und die neue heiße Scheibe von Candida Cicaram so richtig die Songs angesagt hat, um sie dann zu spielen.
Das hatte jetzt was von Helge Schneider.
Ja, das war aber so. Verstehst du, das ist das, was ich meine. Es war einfach real.
Ich war dort.
Ich war einfach da. Und nicht nur das, nein, auf diesem Bettlaken bespannten Teil hatten sie dann auch noch Ausstoff mit der Schere, so einen Schriftzug ausgeschnitten und da drauf genäht, damit das Ganze auch wirklich in die Zukunft geblickt hat. Wir reden von 1988. Da stand dann so ein geschwungener...
Der durfte Westmusik spielen?
Der musste Westmusik. Das war halt für West.
Da saßen so reiche Westhainis, die sich ihre Ostmädels da ausgehalten haben. Und der geile DJ spielte Tandida Tiggerrahmen und dann stand dann in so ausgeschnittenen Stoffbuchstaben Komet 90.
Komet 90?
Ja, das stand da drauf. Das war der DJ wahrscheinlich. Das war, ich weiß nicht, das sollte irgendwie Zukunft und Weltall und Außergewöhnliches. Und ich fühlte mich noch nie so falsch. Wir wollten nur irgendwo was essen und sind dann zufällig da gelandet. Es fühlte sich einfach alles so falsch an. Es war einfach eine falsche Welt. Es war alles verlogen und es sah scheiße aus und alle Leute benahmen sich falsch. Und es war ein einziges Belügen und Geschupse. Und Scheinwelt und Leute wurden verarscht. Und ich war mittendrin und es war wie Facebook.
Da steh ich mal ein bisschen auf.
Lass mich raten, dass auch die Privacy-Einstellung sich gefunden hat.
Ich will das nicht. Ich will nicht in Comet 90 eingesperrt sein.
Ich mag einfach nicht.
Ich will coole Systeme, die einfach für die Leute sind, die gut funktionieren, die irgendwie ihren Share kriegen und die einfach von coolen Leuten in freier Zeit ungebunden entwickelt werden, damit wir alle Spaß haben. Mein Gott, das kann doch alles nicht so schwer sein.
Das hab ich jetzt noch mal einen Medien-Tipp. Nur vaguely related, aber wenn man sich diese Welt, die du gerade beschrieben hast, sich gerne mal angucken möchte, es gibt einen ziemlich geilen sowjetischen Science-Fiction-Film. Roboter im Sternbild der Cassiopeia. Gibt's auf YouTube oder sonst wo. Roboter im Sternbild der Cassiopeia. In der geilen DEFA-Synchronisation. Sehr zu empfehlen. Insbesondere deswegen, weil diese Roboter, wie die sich bewegen, wie die kommunizieren, ist auch schon mal echt der Knaller. Kann ich wie gesagt, und da wird es wie gesagt auch so beschrieben.
Das hab ich neulich gesehen, das ist aber verstörend.
Das ist nicht verstörend. Vor allem die Lösung, wie denn Kinder diese Roboter killen, das ist echt der Knaller. Also wie gesagt, ist so eine kleine Medienempfehlung mal für alle.
Stern Alpha ruft Erde, das passt ja.
Das ist, also wie gesagt, dieses ganze Weltbild ist ja ein sowjetischer Film, aber sozusagen auch so diese... DDR war ja vom Styling her auch so drauf.
Guck mal, deren Google Glass-Band sahen schon viel cooler aus.
Mal so bei Gelegenheit mal gucken. Sehr lustig, das Ding.
Du willst doch wohl nicht sagen, dass die Google-Leute zu wenig sowjetische Science-Fiction gucken.
Anscheinend.
Ich hab... Warte mal, den hab ich glaub ich gesehen hier. Staats-Occasio-Peil, den hab ich aber nicht verstanden. Ist das der erste Teil?
Ich glaub, das ist einfach nur ein anderer Name von dem Ding, seitdem es DVDs gibt. Weil der Original-DV-Titel ist Roboter am Sternbild der Casio-Pyre.
Das ist ein sehr langer Speichel vielleicht.
Die DVD-Edition ist jetzt Start zur Casio-Pyre.
Die DVD-Hülle gibt nicht so viele Buchstaben her. Zumindest am Rand.
Ich kann nicht mal 140 zeichnen.
In meinem Ohr.
Nein, nein, Roboter am Sternbild Casio-Pyre ist die Fortsetzung.
Ach, Tim.
Tim wird angebrummt.
Der brummt schon die ganze Zeit hier.
Aber ich hab gerade auch GSM-Brumm in meinem Kopfhörer gehabt.
Das war nur mein Vibrator hier.
Mit oder ohne Gag-Ball? Darauf antwortet er jetzt nicht mehr, ihr wisst warum.
Mir fällt jetzt nicht mehr viel mehr ein zu diesem ADN-Debakel. Alles ist sehr traurig, aber es ist nicht vorbei. Ihr könnt ja Freunde bleiben. Ich würde auch nach wie vor jedem... Ich besuch dich in deiner schlechten Bar mit dem Pferdefußstühlen. Irgendwas tickt nicht richtig. Wollen wir ernsthaft irgendwie in so eine Zukunft... Ich hab jetzt Frank Riegers Vortrag noch nicht gesehen, der auf der Republik gehalten hat. Ich weiß nur, dass er unter anderem thematisiert hat, wie viel Traffic von welchen Webseiten in diesem Netz gemacht wird. Und dass einfach der Trend ganz klar ist, dass immer alles mehr...
Es ist aber auch die Sternstunde dieses Talks, den Rest fand ich...
Du hast ihn gesehen? Ja gut, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was er im Einzelnen thematisiert hat, was jetzt irgendwie gut oder schlecht war, aber das ist halt so ein Punkt. Es geht einfach hin, dass wir uns von diesen Webseiten diktieren lassen, wie wir kommunizieren sollen und dass wir das dann auch nicht mehr können. Du schreibst was auf diese blöde Facebook und erwartest, dass du deine Kreise damit erreichst, aber du erreichst deine Kreise nicht, weil du halt nur irgendwie nach einem vorbestimmten Schema nur so und so viele Prozent erreichst und den Rest darfst du dann noch dazukaufen. Du darfst ja noch dein eigenes Netzwerk dazukaufen. Also du trägst selber was rein und dann kriegst du es abgenommen und musst dann eben auch noch bezahlen dafür. Ich meine, hallo, was ist denn das? Das ist doch irgendwie Mafia. Das ist doch Schutzgeldzahlung. Das gehört ja doch eigentlich schon so. Dann kommen sie eben so, oh ja, schönes soziales Netzwerk haben sie da.
Schönen Post haben sie da.
Wäre doch schade, wenn niemand das sehen würde. Wäre doch schade, wenn irgendwas passieren würde auf dem Weg.
Du bist einfach umgeben von so digitalen Bullies, die dich einfach die ganze Zeit einfach nur noch belagern. Das ist einfach scheiße.
Das stimmt schon, das stimmt schon. Aber RSS haben wir jetzt auch abgeschafft, die ganzen Sachen, die einfach so funktioniert haben. Es wird ja auch alles nach Google Wave.
Das Schöne an sowas wie RSS ist, das kann mir halt jetzt keiner einfach so nehmen, sondern das existiert halt. Ich kann natürlich aufhören, das zu benutzen, aber wenn ich es benutzen will, kann mich daran keiner hindern.
Ja, aber das ist ja zum Beispiel, das ist jetzt nicht so bidirektionale Kommunikation, aber hat halt auch so Updates so verteilt in die Welt. Aber das haben wir ja sozusagen mit Twitter, mit Jubelgesängen haben wir das ja mit Twitter und so irgendwie abgelöst.
Ja, aber wenn du es ernsthaft, wenn du jetzt ernsthaft so im Newsflow folgen willst, dann bist du mit RSS heute immer noch besser dran als mit Twitter. Das war jetzt so dieses Schnelllebige und dieses jetzt kommt das alles irgendwie in einer Timeline und so. Das war so lange ganz lustig, wie diese Timeline nicht verstopft war. Aber mittlerweile wird dir einfach so viel da reingedrückt. Ja, Folge, Folge mehr, Folge mehr, Folge mehr, vernetze dich, vernetze dich.
Ich habe total wenig Follower und ich followe total wenigen Leuten und bei mir ist die Timeline...
Ja gut, dann ist das halt...
Ich followe 163 Leute.
Ja, von Zeit zu Zeit muss man halt Timeline De-Aid machen. Also das hilft nix.
Tweet die Hälfte.
Der Hockeyler ist eine echte Titelmaschine. Kann man gleich noch in mehrere Sendungen zerteilen.
Du kannst ja die Kapitelmarken mit Überschriften versehen.
Ich glaube die Show notes sind schon dran.
Wie viele Kapitelmarken soll dieses Thema denn noch kriegen?
Letzter Satz noch hier zu ADN. Auf jeden Fall wird da gerade viel Code released, den man sich vielleicht auch mal anschauen möchte als Developer. Auch Clients, dieses Orbit, was ich jetzt nicht so viel benutzt habe. Also viele Sachen werden einfach released und das kann man sich mal angucken. Und das wird sicherlich noch ganz lustig. So, aber wir sollten mal mehr über Apple reden. Es sei denn, ihr wollt jetzt gerade mal über was anderes reden.
Ich könnte da so ein kleines...
Oh, Soundcloud macht sich auch kaputt.
Ich könnte so ein kleines Kryptothema einwerben.
Oh ja, erzähl du doch erstmal.
Und zwar hat mich ein gewisser Philipp angesprochen, der sich irgendwie Deiner oder so ähnlich auf Töter nennt, wie denn das wär. Und ich würd doch auch Mac-Software machen. Und wie denn das mit der SIM-Erweiterung von dem Arm ist und ob ich mich da ausscannen würde. Und ich so, äh, nie, nicht so. Ja, er wär da gerade dabei, mit anderen Leuten irgendwie neues Krypto-Verfahren zu schreiben.
Was heißt denn das, ein Krypto-Verfahren? Also er lässt sich einen Algorithmus einfallen?
Ja, die haben einen symmetrischen Krypto-Algorithmus entwickelt. Der heißt Norgs, N-O-R-X. Auf der Webseite norgs.io gibt's den zum Angucken.
Will der dich trollen?
Wieso?
Na, man schreibt nicht so schnell mal so nebenbei so ein Krypto-Dings.
Äh, na so richtig nebenbei haben sie es wohl auch nicht gemacht. Auf jeden Fall gibt's da irgendwie so ein Wettbewerb, der nennt sich CESA. Ähm, und da haben die den eingereicht und sind, weiß ich nicht, wie weit die jetzt gekommen sind. Ähm, ich hab mir den so ein bisschen angeguckt, weil ich bin jetzt auch kein Mathematiker, aber der hat so ein paar lustige Eigenschaften. Also erstens, er ist schneller als AES, angeblich sicherer als AES und ähm, den kann man parallelisieren. Und das Interessante ist, dass du beim Schlüsselerstellen quasi angeben kannst, wie parallel der laufen soll, wenn du ihn dann äh, kryptest und wieder de-kryptest. Und dadurch kannst du irgendwie einen sehr, sehr schnellen Krypto-Algorithmus machen. Das ist so das... die kurze, schnelle Erklärung.
Die sollen sich mal bei Krypto-Chef melden.
Was, bei Krypto-Chef? Wer ist denn Krypto-Chef?
Na, der hat auch irgendwie irgendwas erfunden, was ultra sicher ist und besser als alles andere und überhaupt und so.
Ich zitiere mal Schneiers Law von Bruce Schneier. Also es ist so... Okay, aber ich will das jetzt gar nicht schlecht...
Warte, liest mal gleich das nächste vor. Ich glaube, der ist auch witzig.
Das nächste.
Von Cory Doctorow.
Naja, das ist hier so die Entwicklung davon. Also Cory Doctorow hat diesen Satz, den er 1998 in seinem Blog geschrieben hat, zu Schneiers Law erhoben. Was sich dann sozusagen ein bisschen verallgemeinert. Any person can invent...
Ne, the security system is so clever, that she or he can't think of how to break it.
Ja, sagt letztlich dasselbe aus, ne?
Ja, grob.
Ja, seine Kerntese ist, dass es einfach nicht sehr einfach ist, was komplett Neues in die Welt zu setzen.
Ja, soweit ich das verstanden hab, basiert das wiederum auf irgendwie einem Hash-Algorithmus, den sich andere Leute ausgedacht haben. Aber verstanden hab ich das alles nicht so richtig. Also da muss ich wirklich aufpassen. Aber es gibt den Source-Code auf GitHub und es gibt eine offene Spezifikation. Die ganzen Kram haben sie ja irgendwie bei diesem CSA-Wettbewerb eingereicht. Ich wünsche denen viel Glück. Als Nebeneffekt meint er, dass dieser Apple A7-Chip unglaublich schnell ist, was seine Benchmarks, die er da mit dem Algorithmus gemacht hat, angeht. Also er kriegt da fast Desktop-Geschwindigkeiten aus diesem Arm-Chip. Raus. Kann man mal so im Auge behalten, was damit passiert?
Ja, man kann sie auch kontaktieren. Wenn 140 Zeichen ausreichen, dann auch Twitter. Wenn es nicht ausreicht, dann vielleicht was.
Anderes. Ich finde den Namen aber auf jeden Fall cool.
Er teilt sich leider zwei von vier Buchstaben mit dem schönen Wort Morks.
Das wird doch bestimmt mit CK geschrieben.
Wir reden das jetzt mal nicht schlecht hier.
Nee, würde ich auch nicht.
Das wollte ich gar nicht. Ja, wollen wir mal über Apple reden? Schon wieder. Und wieder haben wir letztes Mal über Apple geredet.
Max, Pros, Pro Max, Apple Apps.
Na ja, wir können es ja auch ganz kurz machen. Aber irgendwie...
Ja, bitte.
Dieses Gerücht, was es ja eigentlich immer noch ist, dass irgendwie Apple diese Kopfhörerfirma kaufen möchte, das habt ihr schon mitbekommen, oder? Irgendjemand von euch hatte doch welche. Du hast ihn mal erwähnt, als du über die anderen gesprochen hast.
Ja, die haben halt auch Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer in einer ähnlichen Preiskategorie sind. Aber oder waren zumindest damals zu dem Zeitpunkt schlechter in Noise-Canceling als die Bose und sehen halt ein bisschen dicke Hose-mäßige aus. Und da stehe ich nie so drauf.
Ja, aber offensichtlich tun das eine ganze Menge Leute.
Ja, die deutschen Fußball-Nationalmannschaftspieler.
Die rennen alle damit rum. Zumindest die bisherigen, was ja geil ist, wie sich das jetzt auf der nächsten WM so zeigt.
Die sind unglaublich teuer, ne, die Teile?
Ja.
Also wenn man sich da anguckt, was man für den gleichen Preis von Biodynamik kriegt, dann weiß ich nicht, ob die ihren Preis wert sind.
Na wie gesagt, die mit Noise Cancellation sind jetzt nicht teurer als die Konkurrenz unbedingt.
Also das geht glaube ich bis 300 Dollar, 250 Euro oder sowas. Also mittlerweile haben die ja auch verschiedene, die haben ja auch so in-ear drin, aber vor allem diese...
Uns sind protestlich. Also Entschuldigung, aber das geht gar nicht.
Ja, das kommt halt bei den jüngeren Leuten schon ganz gut an.
Also hier gibt es einen für 250...
Professor Headphones.
Genau. Professor Headphones, keine Ahnung. Gibt es in Schwarz, gibt es in Lila, also gibt es in Farben, gibt es vor allem auch mit dem Design, was halt jetzt auffällig ist. Also wenn du jetzt... Guck mal, die meisten anderen, die du jetzt genannt hast, hast du Sennheiser, ich meine, kannst du einen Sennheiser von einem Beyerdynamik, von einem Sony-Kopfhörer auf 20 Meter unterscheiden? Nee, nicht am Sound.
Auf 20 Meter am Sound, klar.
Ne, mal ehrlich, also ich meine, die sind im Wesentlichen alle schwarz vor allem erstmal.
Ja, die sind nicht rot.
Ja, die sind nicht rot und nicht weiß und sind irgendwie... Ja, und sagen wir mal, das Design geht ja hier auch noch ein bisschen weiter bei den Teilen. Also die sind ja, sagen wir mal, jetzt in ihrem gesamten Erscheinungsbild schon so, dass man sie bemerkt. Dazu kommt halt auch noch das relativ präsente Logo dazu und so ist es nun mal. Und dieser Laden funktioniert offensichtlich sehr gut einfach als Brand. So, sie bauen jetzt gar nicht mal Kopfhörer, die jetzt besonders dafür bekannt sind, dass sie besonders gut sind. Sondern...
Sie sind angeblich ziemlich basslastig.
Es hört ja sowieso jeder anders. Also das kann man wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so für allgemein sein. Was jetzt irgendwie besser oder schlechter ist, auf jeden Fall... Verkaufen die sich. Die machen irgendwie fett Umsatz und so weiter. Und das offensichtlich auch mit etwas, wo Apple so bisher sich noch nicht so getummelt hat. Kopfhörer? Kann ja sein, dass das Ganze sich jetzt irgendwie noch zeigt, dass es irgendwie nicht stattfindet.
Ich hab mich bloß gefragt.
Angenommen, das findet jetzt tatsächlich statt. Und sie kaufen jetzt diesen Laden. Dann kaufen sie ihn ja nicht. Wegen Kopfhörer? Wegen der Technik oder wegen der Kopfhörer oder weil Apple nicht in der Lage wäre, Kopfhörer zu bauen. Sondern eigentlich nur... Also der einzige Grund, den Laden zu kaufen, also das eine wäre halt......dass dieses Streaming-Zeug dabei ist.
Das wird zumindest gemutmaßt. Also ich weiß nicht, was da dran ist.
Naja, das bieten die halt auch noch mit an.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird es gemutmaßt, weil sich es auch keiner so recht erklären kann, was das eigentlich soll. Vielleicht ist das auch irgendwie nur der Versuch, diese Dr. Dre-Aktion hochzukriegen.
Oder ein Steuerabschreibungsprojekt.
Na gut, aber ich hab mir also überlegt. Also es gibt ja so zwei Sachen. Entweder sie kaufen den Laden einfach und lassen ihn einfach so weiterlaufen. Damit sie quasi da ein zweites Marktsegment bedienen.
Das hat Apple doch noch nie gemacht.
Na doch, einmal. Also es gibt eine... Beziehungsweise Filemaker.
Ja, das ist jetzt aber auch schon ein paar Jahrzehnte her.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, dass sie es nicht gemacht hätten. Auf der anderen Seite, nur weil sie es noch nie gemacht haben, heißt es ja noch nicht, dass sie es nie tun würden.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber die Theorie steht auf schwachen Beinen, finde ich.
Ich sag nur, was es war. Mehr sag ich ja nicht. Was sollen sie halt sonst mit dem Laden machen? Ich meine, wenn sie den jetzt kaufen und danach die Marke einstellen, was bleibt dann von diesem Laden übrig für Apple? Nix.
Na ja, ein paar Kopfhörer in Entbund.
Na super, aber dafür muss man ja nicht drei Milliarden US-Dollar bezahlen.
Das ist der Preis, der gemunkelt wird?
Das ist der Preis, der gemunkelt wird. Und das ist immerhin ein 5-, 6-faches dessen, was sie mal für Next bezahlt haben. Und ich glaub nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie die Kopfhörer da so... Ich meine, der Laden ist profitabel, der fährt viel Geld, macht viel Umsatz, blablabla. Könnte sich das bezahlt machen.
Aber haben die alle geschrieben, dass es gar nicht um die Kopfhörer geht, sondern um deren Streaming-Angebot?
Ja gut, aber was daran kann Apple nicht machen?
Ja, das sehen wir ja.
Angebot und Streaming und naja, deren.
Nee, ist ja nicht so, dass sie das jetzt technisch nicht auch machen können.
Na ja, also Apple und Internet, ne?
Ja, na gut, aber ich meine, dadurch, dass sie jetzt...
Was ist eigentlich mit diesem iWork-Cloud?
Es kann halt einfach sein, dass sie einfach da so in dieses Business-Modell einsteigen wollen, mit dem sie sich als Apple nicht committen wollen, aber wo sie mal gucken wollen, ob das vielleicht funktioniert und wenn das irgendwie taugt, dann können sie es immer noch übernehmen. Aber auch da weiß ich nicht unbedingt, ob jetzt so diese Akquisition an der Stelle so interessant ist. Diese Beats-Leute haben halt einen relativ guten Deal mit den Musik-Labels. Also die haben halt da irgendwie mehr Musik und irgendwie kriegen da halt Verträge, die Apple als Apple so jetzt nicht bekommt. Und das ist natürlich auch die Frage, ob sie diese Verträge halten können. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich habe über was anderes nachgedacht.
Vielleicht haben die einen Katalog, der sich lohnt und den es noch nicht bei iTunes gibt. Das kann natürlich sein.
Aber jetzt mal ein anderer Gedanke, der mir einfach kam bei dieser ganzen Sache. Was macht man denn mit solchen Kopfhörern?
Rufsetzen? Was macht man mit Apple-Produkten? Benutzen.
Ja, aber was genau machst du mit Kopfhörern?
Sound hören?
Ja, wo kommt der her?
Aus einem Gerät.
Ja, wo ist das?
Hosentasche?
Was für ein Gerät ist das dann? Ja, oder?
Android?
Genau.
Du meinst, die kaufen Beats und ändern einfach die Stecker, dass die nur noch in den iPhone reingepfeiniert werden.
Nein, ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, warum man eigentlich, wenn man schon so ein fettes Teil auf dem Kopf hat und damit durch die Gegend läuft, noch ein anderes Gerät braucht. Also warum...
Meinst du, Apple will für 3 Milliarden so ein bisschen Kopfhörer-Hardware kaufen? Nein, ich hab nicht gesagt, was Apple...
Nee, ich hab nur gesagt, als ich darüber nachgedacht habe, was sie mit diesem Scheiß laden wollen und warum auf einmal Kopfhörer für Apple ein Thema ist, hab ich einfach mal über Kopfhörer nachgedacht.
Statt Google Glass jetzt irgendwie Apple Headphone.
Die einzigen Kopfhörer, die Apple bisher verkauft hat, sind diese kleinen weißen Knöpfchen, die wir alle wissen, nicht unbedingt jetzt gerade die Definition von High-End ist. Und ich lauf immer mit solchen... Oder was heißt immer? Also so oft es für mich möglich ist, hab ich solche Kopfhörer und hab dann so ein langes Kabel da dran, was sich immer irgendwo verfängt, damit es irgendwie mit meinem Telefon zusammenhängt. Ja, jetzt könnte ich natürlich irgendwie Bluetooth und so weiter, aber wir haben alle irgendwie auch schon mal Bluetooth-Kopfhörer gehabt und es hat irgendwie alles gesackt. Weil Verbindungsprobleme, Akku und so weiter.
Ja, ich...
Ich hab das Problem ausgesessen.
Ja, ich hatte welche und es irgendwie sackt so. Man hat irgendwie den Glauben, dass es eigentlich nicht sacken müsste, aber es sackt.
Bumsack return.
Diese Tischseite, da ist heute so ein hohes Potenzial.
Aber wenn jetzt Apple solche Kopfhörer verkauft, auch irgendwie vielleicht als Beats, dann frag ich mich halt, warum muss man dazu eigentlich noch ein iPod dazu verkaufen, der sowieso irgendwie so klein ist, dass man den irgendwo hinstecken muss.
Den hast du am Telefon, den Telefon hast du sowieso dabei.
Ja, es gibt ja auch iPods.
Wie lange noch?
Ja, okay, aber du kannst mittlerweile in der Größe eines kleinen iPods im Prinzip auch die iPhone, also um Streaming zu machen, was irgendwie sich konfiguriert. Du könntest auch noch den Funk dazu auch noch, das 3G und das WLAN, kannst du da auch noch mit reinbauen.
Und wo machst du das Display hin und den Touchscreen?
Das klappt dann runter, so visiermäßig.
Dann nimmst du immer das Teilabtipp da drauf rum und setzt es wieder auf.
Ah, Siri, die anderen wollen auch so, wie sie die ganze Zeit mit ihren Geräten reden. Können sie auch mal mit sich selber reden.
Ich bin nicht überzeugt.
Ich glaube deine Glaskugel ist da trüb heute.
Sind Glaskugeln eigentlich mit Touchscreen? Ich glaube, wenn Apple so was bauen wollen würde, dann könnten sie das auch ohne, dass sie da eine Firma verkaufen. Dass sie Kopfhörer bauen können, die nach was klingen, das haben sie eigentlich bewiesen.
Haben sie? Welches Zeitalter, welcher Stern?
Die In-Ear-Dinger sind ziemlich gut.
Wenn sie mal in ihr bleiben würden, dann wären sie wahrscheinlich super.
Diese mit dem Nüppel, der dicht abschließt, diese Teile, ich halte die gerade mal hoch.
Das sind aber auch nicht die besten In-Ears auf der Welt.
Das sind die normalen In-Ear-Teile, die du dir ins Ohr stöpselst und dann bleiben sie auch drin.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall wird ja gemunkelt, dass dieser Dr. Dre, dieser DJ, Apple-Executive wird. Den Gedanken fand ich dann doch sehr lustig, dass dann so ein rappender Hip-Hopper da irgendwie hinkommt.
Sind wir jetzt schon so weit gekommen mit den Apple-Rooms, dass wir uns dann solche...
Da ist mir was aufgefallen. Und zwar...
Wir haben einen Zombie im Executive-Sport, der hat gar keine Pupillen, oder was?
There's no black man on there.
Also erstmal ist da kein Schwarzer, und zweitens war da ja bis vor ein paar Tagen auch keine Frau. Also diese Angela Arendts ist ja jetzt seit ich denkt...
Aber die haben noch eine Frau im Board, aber...
Ja, aber nicht bei den Executives. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, wann es mal eine Frau bei Apple gab, auf der Executive-Ebene. Fällt mir niemand ein. Also ich hab das die ganzen letzten Jahre immer so mit einem Auge verfolgt und es waren immer Männer. Alles White Men. Und sie ist jetzt irgendwie für Retail die erste Frau, die überhaupt hier dabei ist. Vielleicht wollen sie da jetzt einfach ein bisschen mehr Diversity machen, dann holen sie sich jetzt noch so einen Rapper dazu.
Dann will ich ja auch einen Techno-Diät haben.
Also dein Argument wird immer stichhaltiger.
Ich hab kein Argument, ich versuch mir nur darüber Gedanken zu machen, was da vor sich geht, aber ich seh schon, das ist alles irgendwie nicht euer Thema. Ja, red du doch mal über Apple Software jetzt.
Na, das war ja vorhin letzte Woche. Das Bundle gibt's doch bestimmt jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Nee, so lange laufen die nicht.
Kannst du auch weglassen. Kannst ja erstmal nachgucken.
Ich guck mal nach dem Mac-Update-Bundle. So hieß das Mac-Update.
Hier, Roddy, hast du schon gesehen dein Buch hier?
Mein Buch, genau.
Dein Buch?
Mein Buch wird verfilmt.
Ja, aber er kommt erst, kommt erst sonst wann. Also, das kann dauern.
Ich hab gesagt, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie es nicht verfilmen. Das hab ich gesagt. Und siehste?
Ja, und vor allem Ridley Scott. Und Matt Damon.
Also Matt Damon hat es sich ja gemacht. Ich konnte ihn auch früher nie leiden, aber er wird besser. Super. Das war mal anders.
Also das Buch ist halt...
Der war so auf einer Höhe mit Mark Wahlberg und der geht auch immer noch nicht.
Matt Damon, ich bin der totale Matt Damon-Konvertit, nachdem ich den Film gesehen habe. Good Will Hunting.
Weil da hat er nämlich mit Ben Affleck das Drehbuch geschrieben und ein Oscar bekommen.
Genau, und auch die Rolle gespielt und das war total super. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich fand ja auch schon seinen Action-Film ganz toll.
Elysium, oder welches meinst du? Bonn, Bonn, Bonnstar.
Genau, diese Bonn-Serie. Die fand ich eigentlich auch schon immer sehr nett. So hab ich ihn ehrlich gesagt erst mal kennengelernt. Und danach kam Team America. Wo man dann dachte, oh Gott, alle machen sich über ihn lächerlich. Wahrscheinlich ist er lächerlich, aber das ist ja genau das Gegenteil. Oh nee, der hat irgendwie Rückgrat und was nicht alles. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, der wird aber gut passen.
The Martian, das Buch, was du empfohlen hast, soll verfilmt werden. Von niemand weniger als Ridley Scott.
Hast du es jetzt schon komplett durchgelesen? Ja, klar.
Als ich es vorgestellt hab, hatte ich es verfolgt.
Du hast nur die ersten 20 Seiten verraten. Und ich hab's dann gelesen, das, was du verraten hast, waren die ersten 5 Seiten.
Ja oder so.
Es war wirklich ganz wenig, ganz am Anfang. Ich hab's auch gelesen, hab's relativ verschlungen. Ich hab das Hardcover-Dings da gekauft. Das ist ziemlich fett und groß geschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, so ganz riesengroß ist es gar nicht.
Hast du das im Original oder in einer Übersetzung gelesen?
Ich hab das im Original. Ich hab doch erzählt, dass ich das in Amerika, in Portland...
Ja, da hätt ich halt zuhören müssen.
Da ist sogar die Signatur vom Autor drin, wie ich irgendwie erst hinterher festgestellt hab.
Oh, Signed Copy? Da gibt es auch immer dieses schöne, dieses Foto. Ich weiß nicht, ist das ein Hoax? Das hab ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesehen. Ich flog so in meiner Timeline vorbei so ein Foto. Irgendwie Holy Bible. Und dann hat es so ein Sticker drauf. Signed Copy.
Es steht ja nicht drauf, von wem. Signiert ihr gerne eine Bibel, wenn es ist.
Also ich hab draußen auch gelesen, es ist sehr, sehr kurzweiß, macht Spaß zu lesen. Aber das Ende fand ich dann doch ein bisschen plötzlich. Weil ich dachte, jetzt muss ja auch noch irgendwas kommen, was ihn wieder davon abhält, dass jetzt doch irgendwie alles eventuell so ausgeht, wie es ausgeht. Aber dann zack, auf einmal war Ende.
Ja, aber das fand ich okay. Das war dann auch irgendwann mal gut.
Wahrscheinlich machen sie den Film noch ein bisschen etwas länger. Oder auch nicht. Oder machen noch irgendwie einen Turn rein, mit dem man nicht rechnet.
Hast du jetzt, du hast den Link mit dem Chat gepostet.
Hat man denn alle Themen durch jetzt da?
Will noch jemand was zum Thema Kabel konfigurieren wissen?
Apropos Kabel, da muss ich noch kurz erwähnen, was auch bei diesem Mac Pro Pimpin Guide dabei ist. Und zwar der Typ regt sich auch auf, dass man die Kabel schlecht reinkriegt und dass man nie weiß, wo oben oder unten ist. Und wenn man dann noch unterm Schreibtisch ist, auf seinen Knien im Dunkeln hinter dem Rechner irgendwo im Staub der Kabel stecken muss, dass man ja auch irgendwie alles durchprobieren muss. Und sein Tipp ist, dass man sich, er hat mit so einem weißen Stift irgendwie so Punkte auf die Oberseite der Kabel gemacht, dass immer der weiße Punkt nach oben soll, wenn es in den Rechner reinkommt. Und ich glaube, der Tipp ist nicht so schlecht für jemanden, der viel fummelt. Macht man sich einfach mal so ein paar Punkte drauf. Und dann muss man nicht so viel hin und her drehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, also das Kabel, ich habe ja dieses Bild gepostet auf Twitter. Das war nicht messbar langsamer.
Nee, ist das auch nicht.
Als ein normales konfiguriertes, wie man es halt so aus der Verpackung nimmt, Kabel.
Warum sollte das auch? Also diese moderne Ethernet-Schnittstellen, die sind so stabil, dass die, wenn du die gerade mit so einem kurzen Kabel, was du da gemacht hast, betreibst, hättest du auch vier Nass-Schnössinkel nehmen können. Meinetwegen, oder acht.
Naja, ich hatte halt so ein halbes Meter abgeschnittenes Kabel. Das andere, das Patch, das Verlegekabel, das waren dann schon 15 Meter.
Du hättest sogar Adan vertauschen können und so weiter und so fort. Das gleichen die alles aus. Auf die Strecke ist das nicht so wild. Das funktioniert, wie gesagt, auch mit dreien von acht. Denn nicht ganz so gut, aber das funktioniert auch damit. Also das ist, ja, aber ich würde trotzdem niemanden anraten, das zu tun, weil wer weiß, der nächste führt hinter seinem Aquarium vorbei, wo denn der Spezial-Starter tralala für seine Leuchtstofflampe drin ist oder sonst irgendwas. Ist mir egal. Also irgendwas, irgendwelche Störquellen. Das ist ja der Witz. Je länger das Kabel, desto mehr Dinge kommt es vorbei, die da Potenziale einstrahlen. Potenzial einstrahlen und dann ist es halt eben umso spannender, dass man diese Geschichte einhält mit den ganzen, mit den Adern und mit der Verdrillung der Ader. Wenn du da in deiner Wohnung zu Hause, wo alles friedlich ist, auf zwei, drei Meter so ein Kabel dann machst, hättest du auch nassen Schnürsenkel nehmen können.
Naja, aber es ist halt tatsächlich so, dass man Verlegekabel halt nicht crimpen kann an Stecker.
Es gibt spezielle Stecker dafür, deswegen hab ich gefragt.
Ja, es gibt diesen Stecker, aber der ist dann irgendwie so teuer, dass du dann auch die Dose dafür kriegst.
Ja, macht man wie gesagt auch nicht. Ich hab dann zwei Dosen genommen und fertig. Für den Hobby-Bastler, genau, du gehst halt hier zu U-Beta oder so, nicht in den Baumarkt oder so, dann kaufst du einfach zwei Dosen. Der einzige Nachteil ist, wenn du Dosen wieder hast, brauchst du eigentlich ein LSA-Plus-Auflegewerkzeug. Es gibt immer wieder Leute, die versuchen, das mit einem Schraubenzieher reinzurammen. Da biegst du halt die Federn auf und so. Aber normalerweise, wie gesagt, Verlegekabel, Dose, Dose am Ende und dann jeweils ein Patchkabel und tschüss.
Ja, ja, inzwischen ist es auch so. Ich hab mir nur nicht die Bühe gemacht, die Dosen an die Wand zu schrauben.
Das ganze Zeug, ich seh das ja, vielleicht als kleiner Nachtrag zu der Republikar-Geschichte. Das dauert auch deswegen so lange, weil wir natürlich alles immer wieder nachmessen. Und man kann moderne Gigabit-Switches, kann man auch in versteckten Menüs dazu bitten, mal einen Kabeltest für dich zu machen. Also, die gucken sich den Anwatter, wie vertauscht es ist, ob das alles da ist. Und auch messen die auch die Länge aus von so einem Ding. Das machen so Switches alles. Und ich hatte auch Leitungen, ich geb's jetzt mal offiziell zu, ich hatte auch Gigabit-Leitungen mit über 140 Metern. Die gehen hoch. Also, das ist ein bisschen außerhalb der Speck, aber das geht alles. Also, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Da musst du aber zwei baugleiche Router an den Enden haben, oder?
Nee, du kannst das auch ganz ohne Kabel, dann sagt der es halt offen. Der macht halt einfach, der misst die Reflektion am Ende des Kabels, wenn das offen rumliegt. Und dann hast du da auch eine Länge. Hier wählt das echt jemand, und zwar richtig laut.
Dann weiß ich auch, das ist überhaupt nichts mehr.
Das einzige, was ich komisch fand, ist dieses Tool, mit dem man einfach mal so eine Linespeed messen kann. Voll krass! Das hat irgendwie... Also meine beiden Freebase-D-Büchsen haben irgendwie keine Ahnung. Die eine irgendwie ein Viertel des Speeds gebracht, und die andere irgendwie ein Drittel, aber mit ganz absurd großen Schwankungen. Und ich hab nicht rausgefunden, woran es liegt.
Katja Neulich hat auch schon mal so einen Effekt, dass die BSD an dieser Stelle gar nicht so golden war. Und dann hab ich immer erst im Netzwerk gesucht und irgendwann hab ich mir vielleicht moment test the tester first, dann hab ich mal gegen Linux-Kisten getestet und die hatten das Problem nicht.
Gegen Linux hab ich auch getestet und das hat irgendwie so 10% weniger gemacht als macOS. Irgendjemand schrieb über Twitter, ja guck dir mal die Last an und das war auch echt interessant. Also macOS macht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so eine Prozessorlast von 25% oder so bei diesem IPERF und Linux macht halt irgendwie so nicht messbare 2% oder so. Ist aber 10% langsamer. Dann fragt man sich so, das geht ja ab.
Muss ich genau diese Buffer-Einstellung und sowas da alles angucken.
Das ist echt ein Voodoo.
OS X ist 10% langsamer.
Und wie gesagt, das Freebase wollte das gar nicht. Also sowohl 9 als auch 10 hat irgendwie ganz komische...
IPerf 2. IPerf ist ganz komisch. Es gibt einen IPerf und gibt einen IPerf 2. Das heißt aber, wenn du als Package installierst IPerf oder sowas, bei manchen Package-Systemen, bei manchen musst du dann IPerf 2 installieren. Das ist ganz schräg diese Situation. Das ist auch nicht ganz klar immer. Ich nutze es deswegen ganz gerne, weil es mir vergleichbare Werte gibt. Im Vergleich zu dieser komischen Scheiß-Flash-Applikation, hier speedtest.net, auf dem Browser oder sowas. Das kannst du in deiner Falle auch machen. Und wenn man weiß, wie es sich verhält, gerade im Vergleich. Wenn du sagst, du hast dieselbe Maschine rechts und links und bastelst am Netz in der Mitte rum, dann hast du ja einen sinnvollen Vergleich, egal wie schnell die Maschinen am Ende sind.
Ja, also ich hatte auch zwei Switches dazwischen und das hat sich nicht bemerkt.
Du hast zwei Macs genommen oder was? Was hast du rausgekriegt mit zwei Switches dazwischen?
940.
Ja, ungefähr diesen Bereich hatte ich neulich auch. Genau.
Und dann hab ich den alten Mac umgebootet auf den Linux. Und dann hatte ich nur noch 830 oder so.
Der Ding hat ja noch Parameter, den du tunen kannst.
Ja, kann sein.
Die Windows heißt da machen und drehen und tun. Aber wie gesagt, gerade so als Vergleich, du hast bestehende Systeme, die dir erstmal einmisst, so Test the Tester First, am besten die beiden Kisten direkt mit einem Kabel verbinden.
Hab ich gemacht, ja.
Und dann beliebige Netzwerkequipment dazwischen basteln und dann gucken, wie es sich so fällt. Hab ich, wie gesagt, gerade vor 14 Tagen im Vorbereitung dieser Republika mal gemacht, um spezielle Switch Setup mit dem Router dazwischen zu testen und so und genau mit diesen Werten auch zwischen zwei Macs. Also 939 oder mal 40, also ein bisschen schlussiger.
Aber irgendwie bei dem einen Freebase-Data kamen dann mal 250 und dann mal 380 und dann mal wieder, weiß ich nicht, 300 und so. Also das war ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Dem muss ich irgendwann in einer Musestunde noch mal nachgehen, woran das liegen könnte. Ja, kann ich nichts zu sagen. Vielleicht weiß ja einer der Hörer was.
Ich meine, diese Pool funktioniert ein bisschen anders als die meisten anderen. Die meisten anderen senden für eine bestimmte Zeit und gucken, wie viel Daten sie durchkriegen. Die meisten anderen senden eine bestimmte Datenmenge und gucken, wie lange es dauert. Und rechnen das aus und Apple sendet für eine bestimmte Zeit. Und gucken, wie viel Daten er durchgekriegt hat.
Also weil man dann halt die Zeit hochsetzen kann und dann weiß man, dass man irgendwie einen robusteren Messwert kriegt. Und so, aber...
Kann aber natürlich sein, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwelche Testsysteme hast, auf denen die Uhr rumeiert oder sonst irgendwas, und du länger als 10 Sekunden misst oder so, dass dann komische Werte dabei rauskommen, aber...
Ja, aber es ist ja auf beiden Seiten, ne? Tim eiert auch schon rum.
Tim eiert auch schon rum.
Ich glaub, wir haben's, oder? Wir sollten uns noch mit den letzten Energien zumindest noch in ein halbwegs brauchbares Outro schmeißen, ja.
Ja, drück!
Alles wartet nur auf dich! Wir saugen uns für seit Minuten irgendwelche Themen aus.
Nur weil du den Finger nicht gehoben kriegst.
Wann ist die nächste Sendung?
In zwei Wochen. Also so ist der Plan zumindest. Und der Plan ist ja meistens nicht so schlecht eigentlich, ne? Das wäre dann der 28. Vielleicht noch ein letztes Wort hier in eigener Sache. Da mich immer so viele Leute in den letzten Wochen und Monaten gefragt haben, wie es denn mit Raumzeit weitergeht. Das stimmt.
Sagst du jetzt hier in der Freak Show an, wie es mit der Raumzeit weitergeht?
Nee, ich verweise. Also ich kann kurz einen Management Summary machen, aber ich habe mich dazu ausführlich auf der raumzeitpodcast.de Webseite dazu geäußert. Da haben wir jetzt einen etwas längeren Text. Und ja, die Kurzform ist, Raumzeit in der alten Form gibt es jetzt erstmal so nicht. Die alte Form war, dass ESA und DLR das beauftragt haben, bezahlt haben etc. Und das ist halt Ende letzten Jahres ausgelaufen. Und deswegen gab es jetzt quasi nur noch so die letzten Folgen. Und ja, ich will das aber nicht gehen lassen. Und habe deswegen mit denen verhandelt. Und das war auch der Grund, warum es da so lange Funkstille gab. Weil ich halt einfach darauf aus war, da einen Modus zu finden, wie man das irgendwie erhalten kann. Aber da die es sozusagen von sich aus so nicht erhalten können, habe ich halt gesagt, gut, dann mache ich das halt. So. Und habe jetzt quasi Raumzeit offiziell unter meiner eigenen Regie. Das ist jetzt sozusagen mein Podcast. Auch wenn es da jetzt erstmal noch nichts Neues gibt. Weil das Problem natürlich hier ist, wie immer, das ist ein sehr zeitintensives Projekt gewesen. Weil man da einfach viel reisen muss. Und das ist auch eins dieser Formate, die wir CRI einfach extrem von so einer Präsenz leben. Aber ich sehe da durchaus Möglichkeiten und bin jetzt so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach einem neuen Finanzierungsmodell. Und weiß selber ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so ganz genau, was mir da selbst am liebsten wäre. Also okay, was mir am liebsten wäre, weiß ich. Nämlich, dass es im Prinzip irgendjemanden gibt, der da irgendwie... Der hat mich vor drei Stunden gefragt.
Deswegen hat es Tim nie zum Manager geschrieben.
Okay, ich hätte das jetzt auch gleich zu Ende gebracht.
Vielleicht.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Blablabla.
Aber du hast immer noch den passiven Support, das heißt also Access. Oder du kannst sagen, habt ihr nicht mal jemanden, der zu Sonde XY was weiß?
Nee, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ich meine, das könnte ja im Prinzip auch jeder machen. Das ist nur, dass es nicht jeder macht, weil es halt einfach viel Aufwand ist. Das kostet halt einfach viel Zeit. Und man muss dann eben auch diese Gespräche führen, produzieren, blablabla. Und naja, das ist halt auf jeden Fall der richtige Name, der richtige Titel, die richtige Plattform. Und ich will halt, dass diese Plattform einfach weiterlebt. Und jetzt hab ich das erstmal verkündet, damit erstmal alle wissen, was Sache ist. Und die nächsten Wochen und, weiß nicht, vielleicht Monate werde ich halt schauen, was die neue Basis sein kann. Bietet sich natürlich einiges Mögliches an. Aber ich muss das gut abwägen. Also ob man jetzt Crowdfunding macht oder ob man auf einen neuen Sponsor setzt oder so, was auch immer. Vielleicht gibt's da da so einen weißen Ritter, der so aus den Wolken herbeikommt und zum Projekt passt. Keine Ahnung, deswegen muss sich das alles jetzt erstmal ein bisschen verbreiten. Und vielleicht hat ja jemand eine gute Idee. So, das war's aber auch. Es gibt aber demnächst noch mehr Podcast-Neuigkeiten aus dem Meter noch. Noch lange nicht fertig.
Apropos noch lange nicht fertig, was ist mit den Videos vom Sendezentrum?
Das kommt jetzt, wir sind da gerade so am zusammenschneiden, wie sich die...
Man ist immer noch die Frage, wie es jetzt mit dem Sendegeld ausgeht.
Das ist natürlich noch die große Frage.
Aber das Ende ist noch nicht vorbei.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir erstmal die Videos vom Podcast-Workshop als erstes mal drauf und dann gibt's demnächst noch mehr. Aber es gibt jetzt Sendezentrum auch als YouTube-Account und da wird das irgendwie alles rauslaufen, was ist ja geil. Wie Mio auch noch bedienen müssen, kriegen wir das auch noch hin. Was uns zu dem Ende kommt folgenden Punkt bringt? Nicht alles wieder von vorn!
Nochmal!
Nein!
Einmal mit Profis!
Du hast doch noch ein Filmchen.
Jetzt ist Schluss jetzt hier.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt gleich an. In der Aftershow-Party. Da geht's ja mal richtig zur Sache. Wir sagen Tschüss, das war's und wir verabschieden uns.
Tschau, gute Nacht!